SENATE BDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION
AND SUBCOMMITTEE ON. NUMBER
THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO ORDER- THIS IS JOHN
WHERE TO END AND I'M JOINED
WITH A CHAIR SUSAN EGGMAN OF
SUB THREE AND THERE'S A QUITE
QUICKLY HOOD WE WILL. PASS THE
GAVEL AND SHARE THE
CHAIRMANSHIP OF OUR THROUGH THE
HEARING. I WANT TO GO THROUGH
OUR STANDARD OF. DISCUSSION OF.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO CONDUCT THIS
HEARING- IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN AND HERE'S SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HELP FIGHT HI ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
TODAY HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
SOME AND PRESENT WITH ME. IS
CENTER OCHO BOKE AND- CHAIR
AIKMAN WE EXPECT SENATOR PAN
LIGHT AND QUITE LIKELY TO OTHER
MEMBERS. BUT WE EXPECT
EVERYBODY THAT IS ATTENDING
TODAY TO BE IN PERSON. OR THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. BY ACID
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON SCREEN
STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL.
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALL
WHILE WE'RE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OF THREE. AND ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THE BACKUP ROOM TODAY
AND WE WERE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE I CAN SEE THAT IT'S
POSTED RIGHT NOW ON OUR LIVE
FEED. IT WILL BE JUST DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN IF THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
WE'RE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT ALSO WITH THIS THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY KNOW AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHINGTHE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL'S DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LIKE TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. TODAY'S
HEARING IS OUR LAST HEARING
BEFORE THE MAY REVISION IS
ISSUED TOMORROW AND WILL COVER
A VARIETY OF ISSUES THAT FALL
UNDER THIS SHARE PURVIEW OF SUB
COMMITTEES ONE IN THREE WHILE
SOME INFORMATION IS ALREADY
AVAILABLE ON THE MAY REVISION
PACKAGE THIS HEARING WILL NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED THOSE
ISSUES NO VOTES WILL BE TAKEN
TODAY PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE AT
THE END OF THE HEARING ITEMS
ONCE WE HAVE HEARD. ALL ITEMS.
WITH FAST- SENATOR A MAN DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS WE OPEN HEARING. NO I
WOULD JUST LIKE IT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR AND- AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING- AS WE'RE
GOING FORWARD TO THINK ABOUT
OUR OUR KIDS IN OUR COMMUNITY
BOTH FROM A MENTAL HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS IN THEIR
EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE. SO
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO AS
THESE ISSUES INTERSECT IN AS
WERE. COMING OUT OF COVERT AND
MOVING BACK INTO THIS WORLD
WITH A- WITH MONEY TO SPEND TO
FIGURE OUT THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO DO IT FOR THE HEALTH OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU US SENATOR TROUBLED
GERMANY OPENING COMMENTS
CORRECT. THEN WE'LL MOVE
DIRECTLY TO THE FIRST PANEL.
WHICH IS CHILD CARE OVERVIEW
PRIORITIES AND STAKEHOLDER
PERSPECTIVES WILL BE JOINED BY
SARAH CORTEZ OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE CHRISTINA
FIGUEROA WHO IS A PARENT. LOUIS
MARQUEZ WHO IS A PARENT. DONNA
SNEER INJURE WHO IS CHIEF
OPERATIONS OFFICE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER. NEED A BUFFET
WHO'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA AND
QUICHE AND JULIE DIRECTOR OF A
PUBLIC POLICY FOR THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE. AND REFERRAL
NETWORK WE ALSO HAVE-
PRESENTATIONS BY DENISE KELLER
WHO'S A PROVIDER. AND ANGIE
GARGLING WHO'S VICE PRESIDENT
OF EARLY CHILD CARE AND
EDUCATION LOW INCOME INVESTMENT
FUND- WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE BUT WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
LIST TO KNOW THAT PEOPLE WILL
BE CALLING IN. ARE WE JUST HOPE
THAT TO OUR OUR PANELISTS WILL
BE ASSISTING AS POSSIBLE. SO
WITH THAT WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
SERRA CORTEZ. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE MORNING
SERICITIZED THE LEGISLATE AND
OFFICE. I WAS ASKED TO GIVE A
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE
SUBSIDIZED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND DISCUSS THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND DESCRIBE THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC. CAUCUS
PROPOSAL. THE STATES WILL JUMP
INTO THE- REVEALS THE STATE
SUBSIDIZES SEVERAL CHILDCARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THE
STATE SPENDS ROUGHLY FIVE POINT
EIGHT BILLION TO SERVE AN
ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THESE
PROGRAMS. OUR CHILD CARE THE
STATE SERVICE CALL CHILDREN
MEETING ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS THE AMOUNT
OF CHILDREN SERVICE GENERALLY
SET ANNUALLY BY THE STATE
DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS. THE
STATE HAS TWO TYPES OF CHILD
BASED PROGRAMS ARE DIRECT
CONTRACTOR RAMS. AFTER BASED
PROGRAMS PRIMARILY COVER
CHILDCARE ANY ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR THESE PROGRAMS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE
REIMBURSED BASED ON THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. THE RATE
ITSELF IS BASED ON A SURVEY
CONDUCTED EVERY OTHER YEAR BUT
THE STATE DETERMINES WHAT TO
READ TO USE AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY USING THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURVEY. THREE VARIES BY
COUNTY AGE OF CHILD CERTAIN
AMOUNT HERE USE AND THE TYPE OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDER. FOR THESE
PROGRAMS FAMILIES WILL GAIN
ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILD CARE A
WITH THE COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OR AN ALTERNATE TEAM
AGENCY. ONCE THE FAMILIES
RECEIVE ELIGIBILITY YOU CAN USE
THE VOUCHER TO RECEIVE CHILD
CAREFROM ANY PROVIDER IN HER
FIRST IN ANY SETTING UP HER
FIRST. WE ALSO HAVE DIRECT
CONTACT WITH MINORS PRIMARILY
PROVIDERS PARTICIPATING IN
STATE PRESCHOOL OR THE GENERAL
CHILDCARE PROGRAM. CONTRACT
PROVIDERS ARE REIMBURSED BY THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
RESET ANNUALLY BYTHE STATE.
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
IS ADJUSTED BY AGE AMOUNT OF
CARE USE AND OTHER FACTORS. IT
WAS NOTABLY DIFFERENT FROM THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT HAVE A GEOGRAPHIC
ADJUSTMENT. THESE PROVIDERS
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE TO
SERVE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
CHILDREN. FAMILIES WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE CONTRACTED
PROVIDER. TO BECOME INVOLVED IN
THESE PROGRAMS. H. FIVE YEAR
AGENDA BEGINS ON THE- ON THE
CAN IN ON. PER AND THE STATE
RESPONSE CHILDCARE PROVIDER
HOWEVER YOUR- BUT ARE SERVING
YOUR- ARE. LONG OF INCOME DUE
TO START LAST OPENING.
PROVIDERS ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING
HIGHER OPERATION COSTS DUE TO
CLEANING SANITATION. OTHER
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
SIX OF YOUR HAS INFORMATION
ABOUT LICENSE CLOSURES. THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
FACILITIES CLOSED CURRENTLY
OVER THE LAST YEAR ANNUALLY-
SIX THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FACILITIES WERE TEMPORARY CLOSE
AT THE END OF MARCH. ON PAGE
SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA HAS A
TABLE THAT SHOWS THE FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT WERE PROVIDED
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHILD CARE. IN
TOTAL THE THREE PACKAGES AND
MADE FIVE BILLION AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT CHILD CARE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. HE AGE- EIGHT OF YOUR
AGENDA AND SHOWS HOW THESE
FUNDS WERE APPROPRIATED SO FAR
THE STATE HAS APPROVED READ
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION OF THESE FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDS. THE STATE IS STILL NEEDS
TO APPROPRIATE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO MILLION OF THE
CHRISTA FINDS IT AND THEN.
EIGHTY BILLION THE A. R. T.
THEY'RE VERY ANALYSIS WE
PROVIDED ISSUES THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER HOW TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT PROVIDERS
AND FAMILIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC WITH THE REMAINDER
THESE TIMES THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER ACTIONS OF THE
STATE COULD IMPLEMENT QUICKLY
GIVEN THE IMMEDIATE ISSUES
CREATED BY THE COAL IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY- THIS INCLUDES USING
EXISTING PROGRAMS EXTENDING
EXISTING PANDEMIC ACTIONS AND
USING SOME SIMPLE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGIES. I JUST THINK
YOUR MAIL WANT TO SPEND
HEALTHCARE PLANS OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS GIVEN THE SUPPLEMENTAL CZ
GPG FUNDS FROM THE A. R. P. CAN
BE SPENT THROUGH SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO APPROPRIATE ALL THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM. IN THE CURRENT BUDGET
CYCLE. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER MODIFYING FLEXIBILITY
STREET IN ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
THE HAND WE PROVIDED OUR
ANALYSIS IS LEAVING FAMILY
FEAST- WE WOULD FURTHER NOTE.
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. AVAILABLE IS A
ONE TIME FUNDING DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PRIORITIZED USING SOME OF THESE
ONE TIME FUNDS TO PROVIDE
TEMPORARY SLOTS FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. WITHOUT ONGOING
FUNDING HOWEVER FAMILY
RECEIVING TEMPORARY SOFTLY BUT
ACTUALLY BE DISTANT ROLLED-
STAFF A BRIEFLY DESCRIBE THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
PROPOSAL. TO PAGE NINE OF YOUR
GENDER DESCRIBES THIS PROPOSAL
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS PROPOSING
MAKING PROGRESS IN A NUMBER OF
PRIORITY AREAS THESE INCLUDE. A
SIGNIFICANT STEP UP TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AN ADDITIONAL
CHILD CARE SLOTS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES IS THE NEXT STEP
TOWARD UNIVERSAL ACCESS FOR
AGES ZERO TO THREE. ESTABLISH A
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT CHILDCARE
WORKER POSITION TRAINING
PROGRAMS REDUCE COSTS TO
WORKING FAMILIES BY EDUCING
AND ELIMINATING FAMILY FEES.
INCREASE PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT
RATES TO ACHIEVE A LITTLE A
LITTLE WAGE FOR CHILDCARE
WORKERS. STABLE LIFE AND REMAIN
AND RETAIN THAT PROVIDERS AT
THE STATE EMERGES FROM THE
PANDEMIC SUPPORT PROVIDERS THAT
HAVE REMAINED OPEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC BY CONTINUING HOLD
HARMLESS POLICIES. PROVIDE ONE
TIME FUNDS TO HELP PROVIDERS
WHO HAVE CLOSED- TO REOPEN OR
THOSE WHO ARE OPEN TO EXPAND
RETAINED ITS CENTRAL WORKERS-
FAMILIES IN THE. CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. IS MY REMARKS BUT TO
TAKE QUESTIONS THE- TIME. THANK
VERY MUCH SHOW WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD QUESTION UNTIL THE END. OF
THE PRESENTATION OF ALL PALACE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
CHRISTINA FIGUEROA NEXT. I DO
NOT SEE HER HERE FURTHER SHE IS.
THERE SHE IS WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
FIGUEROA- I AM A FULL TIME
WORKING PARENT RECEIVING A
CHILD CARE SUBSIDY IN SOUTH
KING COUNTY.I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN. TWO OF WHICH ATTEND A
LOCAL CHILD CARE CENTERS THAT
THEY LOVED IN ABIT TENDING NOW
FOR THREE YEARS. I WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE MY WORK AND
SUPPORT. MY CHILDREN WITHOUT MY
CHILD CARE CENTER AND MY CHILD
CARE SUBSIDY. CHILD CARE IS SO
IMPORTANT TO BOTH ME AND MY
CHILDREN. ON MOST DAYS THEY
DON'T EVEN SAY GOODBYE TO ME
WHEN I'M DROPPING THEM OFF
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO BUSY RUNNING
OFF TO SAY GOOD MORNING AND
HELLO TO THEIR TEACHERS AND
OTHER STUDENTS. EVEN ON TOUGH
DAYS IN THE MORNING SOME DAYS
ARE TOUGH. I'M NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL WITH. BRIGHT SMILES ON
THEIR FACES READY TO ENJOY THE
DAY. I SEE THEIR LIVES
POSITIVELY BEING INFLUENCED. BY
THE TEACHERS IN THE PROGRAM AND
THE STUDENTS THAT. THEY'RE ABLE
TO SEE EVERY DAY ESPECIALLY
WITH CORPORATE SPENDING AND
TOUGH WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND BEING AWAY FROM FRIENDS.
WITH THAT BEING SAID ONE OF THE
MAJOR FINANCIAL FACTORS I HAVE
TO STRUGGLE WITH EVERY MONTH
IT'S MY FAMILY FEE. I PAY A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DOLLARS A
MONTH AND SHE STRUGGLES EVERY
MONTH. TO KEEP UP WITH PAYING
MY FEET. IN ORDER TO KEEP MY
CHILD CARE SUBSIDY I HAVE TO
PAY THIS FEE. OTHERWISE I COULD
BE TERMINATED FROM THE PROGRAM.
FOR SEVERAL MONTHS IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. THE
STATE WAIVES FEES FOR ALL
FAMILIES. DURING THIS TIME MY
STRESS LEVEL WAS SO MUCH LOWER.
I FINALLY HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
WIGGLE ROOM. I WAS ABLE TO USE
THE MONEY THAT I SAVED. FROM
FAMILY FEES TO BE ABLE TO BUY
NEW TIRES THAT I DESPERATELY
NEEDED FOR MY CAR. I WAS EVEN
ABLE TO HANDLE LIFE UNEXPECTED
LIFE CHANGES AND CHALLENGES.
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO OVERCOME
THEM. BECAUSE I HAD THE EXTRA
LITTLE REAL ESTATE THAT SAVED
MONEY FROM MY FAMILY FEES. BUT
THEN AT THE BEGINNING OF
SEPTEMBER. SEPTEMBER FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. BECAUSE I'M IN
A CENTRAL WORKER AND WAS USING
IN PERSON CHILDCARE. I STARTED
PAYING FEES AGAIN. AND OUT A
FAMILY FEES ARE WAIVED I COULD
PAY DOWN SOME OF MY CENTRAL
BILLS LIKE P. JEANNIE AND WATER
FOR EXAMPLE. BAMA'S WIN BE
WORRIED ABOUT LOSING THE CHILD
CARE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PAY THE
FEES OR FOR THAT. THE MONEY THE
MONEY IS NEEDED FOR BILLS FOR
SHOES CLOTHING FOR KIDS. WHY IS
CALIFORNIA PENALIZE WITH
PARENTS WHO NEED HELP PAYING
FOR CHILDCARE. BUT STILL SHE
CHARGES FEES WHEN WE CAN'T
AFFORD IT. I WOULD ALSO USE THE
MONEY TO SUPPORT MY CHILDREN
WITH EXTRA CURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES. THAT THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO DO AND I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD. YEAH
BECAUSE I'M TAKING ALL OF MY
OTHER BILLS AND MAKING SURE TO
KEEP UP WITH THEM. MY BOYS WANT
TO PLAY SPORTS AND MY DAUGHTER
HAS BEEN ASKING ME REPEATEDLY
TO JOIN A DANCE CLASS
ESPECIALLY SINCE THINGS ARE
BECOMING NORMAL- SAYS THAT THEY
HAD TO MAKE. OF COURSE
FOLLOWING SAFETY PROTOCOLS BUT
CAN JUST ONE OF THE KIDS AND
HAVE FUN AND- BE AROUND. THIRD
AT THEIR PEERS. SOLUTION THE
FAMILY FEUD THE FAMILY HE
PROBLEM IS TO WAIVE FEES. IS TO
WAIVE THE FEES TO BRING
IMMEDIATE HELP TO FAMILIES LIKE
MINE WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO WAIVE
THESE FEES ARE CURRENT FAMILIES
AND FOR EVERY NEW SLOT THAT YOU
ADD. TO MAKE SURE THE FUNDING
INCLUDES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE- THE SLOTS THAT YOU ADD.
INCLUDE HER FAMILY FEES BE
WAIVED ALSO. WITH THE SEVENTY
SIX BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS THE
FEDERAL CHILD CARE RELIEF WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY NOW LIKE
NEVER BEFORE TO HELP THE
FAMILIES. THE WORKING FAMILIES
OF CALIFORNIA NEED YOUR
SUPPORT. RIGHT NOW NOW IS THE
TIME FOR ACTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WILLING TO GIVE US YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU AND
THE NEXT WILL BE LILY MARQUEZ
ALSO APPARENT. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. HI EVERYBODY HI
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS LESLIE
MARQUEZ I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF PARENT
VOICES I AM A MOTHER OF A FIVE
YEAR OLD BOY AND A FIVE YEAR
OLD BOY AND A FOUR YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER. I'M HERE JUST TODAY
AT COMMENT AND SHARE MY STORY
AS IT RELATES TO CHILD CARE BUT
HOPES THAT EVERYONE ON THIS
CALL. IS ABLE TO SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF CHILD CARE EARLY
LEARNING FOR CHILDREN. I'VE HAD
A LONG ISSUE WITH BEING ON THE
WAIT LIST I WAS A WORKING
PROFESSIONAL HIGHER EDUCATION.
UNTIL SIX YEARS AGO WHEN I
STARTED PLANNING FOR A FAMILY.
I WAS BLESSED TO BECOME A
MOTHER TO A BOY YEARS AGO SIX
YEARS AGO AND I WAS ABLE TO
WORK PART TIME EVEN AFTER MY
MATERNITY LEAVE. AND I ARRANGED
FOR AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE FOR
HIM ON A PART TIME BASIS.
EVERYTHING WAS FINE UNTIL I
BECAME PREGNANT WITH MY SECOND
CHILD WHICH WASN'T PLANNED. BUT
YEAH MY JOB VALUED ME SO MUCH
THAT I HAD A FLEXIBILITY WITH
MY WORK SCHEDULE WHEN I HAD
WENT AHEAD AND WENT ON MY
MATERNITY LEAVE. I STRUGGLED TO
FIND AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE AND
QUALITY CHILDCARE FOR TRUE BABY.
SO I MADE A HARD LIFE DECISION
TO GIVE UP MY CAREER. I GAVE UP
NO I GAVE MY NOTICE. I SOLD MY
HOME AND I MOVED TO ANOTHER
CITY. INTO WITH MY FROM MY
HUSBAND'S FAMILY DUE TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. THE LACK OF
AFFORDABILITY ACCESSIBILITY AND
AVAILABILITY OF CHILD CARE
WHAT'S THE REASON FOR ME TO
BECOME A STAY HOME MOM. I WAS
LIVING WITH ONE WORKING ADULT
THE TWO DISABLED ELDERLY WOMEN
AND TWO BABIES. AND I LIVING IN
A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT SIX OF
US THAT INCREASED OUR STRESS
LEVELS AND AFFECTED MY MENTAL
HEALTH. THREE YEARS AGO IWAS
OFFERED A JOB AS AN ESSENTIAL
WORKER. AND THAT'S WHEN I
DECIDED TO MAKE A CHILD TRAPPED
THE CASE FOR MY CHILDREN. I
WANTED TO FOCUS ON MY WORK
HOWEVER I WAS PLACED ON THE
WAITLIST. AND AS A PANDEMIC
BEGAN THE PERSON THAT TOOK CARE
OF NEEDED MORE OF MY ATTENTION.
AND UNFORTUNATELY MY SON WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH SPECIAL NEEDS SO
HE NEEDED ME TO. SO I HAD TO
QUIT MY JOB AGAIN DUE TO THE
LACK OF HEALTH CARE I COULDN'T
GET MY FIVE YEAR OLD CHILD CARE
OR INTO AN EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM HE HAS NOW STARTED
KINDERGARTEN. LAST YEAR AND
HE'S BEEN HE WAS DOING IT.
ONLINE AND- HE JUST STARTED IN
PERSON LEARNING TWO THREE WEEKS
AGO AND HE'S BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY EMOTIONALLY AND
SOCIALLY. HE LAST WEEK GOT A
COLD AND SO I SUBMITTED HIM
INTO A CORPORATE TEST TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN OTHER PROTOCOL. OR YOU
HAVE TO QUARANTINE SO I HAD TO
TAKE THE TEST HE WAS NEGATIVE
SO MY CONCERN WAS MAKING SURE
THAT THE SCHOOL HAD. THE
PROTOCOL THE PROPER FOR HIM TO
GO BACK TO SCHOOL SAFELY. THE
FASHION PPO SUPPLIES. SO THAT
I'M NOT CONCERNED OF. I'M CLING
FINANCE. AND ENVIRONMENT SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT. BUT HE CAN'T DRIVE
JOIN ONLINE LEARNING STYLE IN
PERSON LEARNING IS THE ONLY WAY
THAT HE WILL BE ABLE TO LEARN
AND GROW AND THAT'S- THE ONLY
OPTION THAT I HAVE FOR HIM. TO
LEARN. SO THAT'S THE RISK BUT
I'M TAKING WITH HIM. AND RIGHT
NOW I'M CURRENTLY ON THE WAIT
LIST FOR MY FOUR YEAR OLD TO
GET CHILD CARE WHICH I HOPE
THAT SHE GETS PLACEMENTS. I
APPLIED WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO GET MY DAUGHTER
INTO A TEACHING PROGRAM. AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS LIMITED
TICKETS GOALS. SO IT'S NOT EVEN
A- REQUIREMENT. OF WHAT I WAS
TOLD THAT A FOUR YEAR OLD. TO
GET INTO AN EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM. SO I HAVE A HUGE FEAR
OF NOT. IN MY CHILD CARE FOR MY
DAUGHTER. EITHER ENTITY K.
PROGRAM OR INTO EARLY LEARNING
AND HAVE HER STRUGGLING LIKE MY
SON IS NOW. SO THE LACK OF
AFFORDABILITY AND THE ACCESS IS
REAL. MAKING SURE FAMILIES ARE
NOT ON THE WAITING LIST FOR
VERY LONG AND ONCE THEY GET
PLACED. THEY HAVE THEIR FEES
WAIT. FOR STRUGGLING FAMILIES
LIKE MINE. BECAUSE IT'S HARD
ENOUGH BUT DEMOCRATS ONLY MADE
IT WORSE. HAVING TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN BEING A PARENT AND
WORKING IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
ANYBODY SHOULD GO THROUGH ALSO
STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY TO
PROVIDE ALONG WITH PAYING FOR
CHILD CARE AND FAMILY FEEDS CAN
POSE A HUGE BURDEN. THANKS FOR
STAYING HOME BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE QUALITY.
ACCESSIBLE CHILD CARE AND THE
MENTAL STRESS IS WHAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT A PARENT SHOULD
GO THROUGH EITHER. PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
NECESSITIES THE BASIC
NECESSITIES LONG CHILD CARE
WAITLISTS FAMILY FEEDS. FOR THE
CONCERN THAT QUALITY CHILD CARE
AND A LACK OF PORTABILITY CARE.
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES THE FAMILY
SHOULD BE ON THE WAY IT SHOULD
BE ON THE WAIT LIST FOR THREE
YEARS THAT'S UST TOO LONG AND
YOU CANNOT GET THAT TIME BACK I
CAN'T GET THAT. I WANT. TELL ME
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE WEIGHED.
MORE WAITING LIST SHOULD BE
ACCESSIBLE AND AVAILABLE. I
THOUGHT THAT HE SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES
INCLUDING FAMILIES
PARTICIPATING ON CAL WORKS
THERE SHOULD BE T. K. PROGRAMS
FOR ALL KIDS TWIN CREEKS BEND
TO PREPARE. OR EDUCATION
SETTING SO THAT THEY'RE NOT
BEHIND WHEN THEY START
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT I INVESTED TIME
TALKING TO EARLY LEARNING
ADMINISTRATORS AND SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED STAFF THAT
HAVE THAT AS OF RIGHT NOW CAN'T
GIVE ME A DIRECT ANSWER WITH
REGARDS TO THE SELECTION
PROCESS FOR. MY CHILDREN'S WAIT
LIST. I STRUGGLE PUTTING MY SON
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO CHECK.
INTO AN EARLY LEARNING PROGRAM.
AND CHILD CARE SO HE HAD TO
GROW WITHOUT THAT. AND NOW HE
STARTED KINDERGARTEN.
KINDERGARTEN ANY STRUGGLING
MORE THAN EVER. SO I'M
STRUGGLING NOW TO PUT MY FOUR
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER INTO A
TEACHING PROGRAM EVEN THOUGH I
APPLIED EARLY ON LAST YEAR.
THERE ALSO NEEDS TO BE A
SUPPORT FOR LEBANON FAMILY'S.
HISPANIC FAMILIES AND MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR LANGUAGE
SERVICES. AND OTHER TARGETED
CULTURAL NEEDS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT AND WELL BEING OF
THE CHILDREN IN THE FAMILY.
CHILD CARE SERVICES NEED TO BE
PRIORITIZED TO BENEFIT
EVERYONE'S MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL BEING. ESPECIALLY WITH
THE PANDEMIC THAT HAS AFFECTED
US IN SO MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS
AND SOME ANYWAY. THE FIRST
YEARS OF A CHILD IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONES AND THERE NEEDS
TO BE A HUGE INVESTMENT CHILD
CARE CHILDREN OUR FUTURE. AND
WANTS PARENTS CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR KIDS ARE TAKING CARE
OF THAT WORLD AND STRENGTHEN
OUR ECONOMY BY ALLOWING FANS TO
FOCUS ON WORKING AND
CONTRIBUTING BACK. CHILDREN
WILL BECOME HEALTHY AND DRIVE
IN THIS WORLD SO CHILDREN OUR
FUTURE AND WE SHOULD INVEST IN
THEM AND HELP THEM DEVELOP
THEIR ACADEMIC. PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL AND SOCIAL WORK. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
THEY WERE. REMARKABLY MOVING
AND I KNOW IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
HARD SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO OR DONNA SNEER INJURE WHO
FROM THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. GOOD AFTERNOON IS NOW
NEWS ALSO AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
DONNA SNARE DRUM THE CHIEF
STRATEGY OFFICER FOR THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME
TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
CHILDCARE INVESTMENTS IN THE
STATE BUDGET. I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK SENATE LEADERSHIP FOR
THEIR CHILD CARE PLAN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU. AS WE WORK TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN THE SYSTEM. MANY
OF US HAVE KNOWN THAT CHILD
CARE HAS BEEN A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
ALLALONG. THE PANDEMIC SHONE A
BRIGHT LIGHT ON THE NEEDS FOR
CHILD CARE TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
ESPECIALLY OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
FOR PARENTS TO GET TO WORK AND
SUPPORT OUR STATE DURING A
CRISIS. WHAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WERE SHATTERED AND SHIFTED TO
DISTANCE LEARNING TO KEEP
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF STATE
CHILDCARE WAS DECLARED AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE AND MOST OF
OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
REMAINED OPEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE OF OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
LARGELY WOMEN OF COLOR HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES DURING
THE PANDEMIC CARING FOR
CHILDREN IN OUR HEALTH CARE
FOOD SERVICE PUBLIC SAFETYAND
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS. ARE
CHILDCARE HEROES AT RISK TO
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND THE HEALTH
OF THEIR FAMILIES WERE OPEN
CARING FOR CHILDREN AND
SUPPORTING DISTANCE LEARNING.
SADLY THEY WERE DOING THIS WITH
COMPENSATION PROVIDED BY STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THAT ARE
FALLING BEHIND THE COST OF THE
MARKET IN AN ANTIQUATED. SYSTEM
WHICH DOESN'T PROVIDE FOR. I
AND ADD COMPENSATION. IT'S TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO STEP UP AND
DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THESE
ESSENTIAL CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
BY INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR ALL PROVIDERS AND
REFORMING OUR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES SYSTEM AS PROPOSED IN
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY SIX
AUTHORED BY SENATOR LEYVA TO A
MODERN STRUCTURE WHICH BEGINS
TO MOVE US TO A MORE EQUITABLE
RATE STRUCTURE USING THE MOST
CURRENT WHICH WOULD BE THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN R. M. R.
SURVEY. AND MOVING TOWARD A
SINGLE SIMPLIFIED STRUCTURE FOR
PAYMENTS. WHILE MOST PROVIDERS
HAVE REMAINED OPEN AS YOUR
AGENDA NOTES MANY PROVIDERS
HAVE HAD TO CLOSE THEIR
OPERATIONS BECAUSE OF REDUCED
ENROLLMENT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL HEALTH CONCERNS AND
DECLINED ENROLLMENTS AS MANY
EMPLOYEES SHIFTED AT HOME FOR
SAFETY. THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
36% OF OUR CHILD CARE CENTERS
AND 20%OF OUR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE STILL
CLOSED. AND THOSE THAT ARE
OPERATING ARE OPERATING AT
REDUCED ENROLLMENT STOOD A
COVETED SAFETY CAPACITIES. TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S FULL
RECOVERY FROM THE PANDEMIC WE
MUST ALLOCATE STATE AND FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO GET THESE
PROVIDERS BACK OPEN AND ON
THEIR FEET. WE NEED TO INCREASE
OUR REFORM REIMBURSEMENT RATES
OTHERWISE PEOPLE WON'T COME
BACK. WE NEED TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO HELP CHILD
CARE BUSINESSES CATCH UP WITH
THE FINANCIAL LOSSES THEY'VE
WEATHERED DURING THE COVERT
OPERATIONS. AND WE NEED TO
PROVIDE RE OPENING AND RESTART
INCENTIVES TO BRING OUR CLOSED
PROVIDERS BACK. WE ALSO NEED TO
OFFER RECRUITMENT INCENTIVES
FOR PEOPLE TO COME INTO THIS
BUSINESS AND OPERATE CHILDCARE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR DISCUSSION OF
THIS TOPIC TODAY AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AFTER THE
PANEL'S COMPLETE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION. NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO NINA BUT SAY BUT SEE
HOPEFULLY I'M PRONOUNCING YOUR
NAME RIGHT. FROM THE EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUES MY NAME
IS NINA BIRTHDAY I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AVERAGE
HOW CALIFORNIA. WE ARE A
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED SUBSIDIZED
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
AGENCIES IN THE STATE
REPRESENTING 65% OF ALL
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS. WE'RE IN
AN INCREDIBLE TIME TO MAKE THE
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED TO
ENABLE SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE AND
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO
BETTER SERVE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. AND BUILD A STRONGER
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE SYSTEM.
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
EMERGENCY INCREASES TO EARLY
CARE THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FIELD AS THE KIND OF
IT NINETEEN PANDEMIC PROGRESSED
BUT AS WE LOOK TO THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO STATE BUDGET AND
FEDERAL FUNDS INVESTMENT.
THERE'S MUCH MORE THAT CAN BE
DONE TO STABILIZE AND BUILD UP
THE CHILD CARES SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
THAT COULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
REQUEST. THE FIRST WOULD BE A
HOLD HARMLESS FOR PROGRAMS FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- AS WAS
NOTED BY MY PREVIOUS PANELISTS
AS PROGRAMS RE OPEN THEY ARE
BEING HELD JUST SOCIAL
DISTANCING ROLLS AND REDUCED
CAPACITY. CAPACITY OF PROGRAMS
WILL ALSO BE DOWN FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR
THEREFORE FULLY FUNDING
PROGRAMS WITH A HOLD HARMLESS
CLAUSE WOULD ALLOW PROGRAMS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR FULL. CONTRACT
FUNDING WHAT PROVIDER PROVIDING
CARE TO CHILDREN UNDER CURRENT
GUIDANCE AND TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT DURING THE AFTERMATH
OF THE OUTBREAK WE ARE IN SUCH
AN EINER STABLE SITUATION RIGHT
NOW. AND WE REALLY NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
MADE WHOLE SO THAT BE I MEAN.
THE INCREASE CLOSURES DO NOT
CONTINUE ALSO LEARNING FROM THE
CO GOOD NINETEEN PANDEMIC A
CHANGE THAT WE CAN MAKE
PERMANENTLY THAT WOULD BE
FRIENDLY TO FAMILIES AND
PROVIDE STABILITY TO PROVIDERS.
WOULD BE TO REIMBURSE SUBSIDIZE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING DIRECT
CONTRACTING CENTERS ABOUT YOUR
CHILD CARE CENTERS FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS BASED ON
ENROLLMENT. NOT ATTENDANCE
REIMBURSING FOR CHUCK SUBSIDY
FOR RAW ALLOW MAX STAY. FOR
PROVIDE. ALLOWING THEM TO STAY
OPEN REGARDLESS OF THE
ATTENDANCE PATTERNS OF CHILDREN
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT- COVE IT
IT'S STILL GOING ON WE ARE
STILL HAVING OPENING ENCLOSURE
SO THIS WILL CONTINUE THREE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I'M ALSO
A GREAT REFORM FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AS
REFERENCED BY DONNA SALINGER.
WE RECOMMEND ESTABLISHING A
SINGLE REAR REGIONALI STATE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM FOR
SUBSIDIZED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. THIS SINGLE
SYSTEM AS A STEP TO RIGHT SIZE
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURING CALIFORNIA AND TO
INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMSPRING
CREEK CREEK QUALITY WHILE
RECOGNIZING REGIONAL AND AGE
COST DIFFERENCE SAYS. I NEED
ANOTHER PERMANENT CHANGE- THAT
COULD BE USED TO REMOVE
BARRIERS AND ALLOW PROGRAMS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS TO EXPAND THE AGES OF
CHILDREN SERVED SO THAT THEY
CAN SERVE MORE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS IN QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING SETTINGS AS AS ONE OF
YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS. IN YOUR
BUDGET PRIORITIES WE ALSO
RECOMMEND EXPANSION TO CHILD
CARE SPACES INCLUDING TITLE
FIVE PROGRAMS DIRECT
CONTRACTING AND BELCHER
PROVIDERS UTILIZING FEDERAL AND
GENERAL FUNDS. THERE ARE STILL
VERY LONG WAITING LIST AS WE
HEARD FROM OUR PARENTS TODAY
AND THERE ARE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF ELIGIBLE CHILDREN WHO AREN'T
STILL NOT RECEIVING CARE.
ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW THERE'S AN
INCREDIBLE NEED FOR INCREASED
INFANT AND TODDLER CARE DIRECT
CONTRACTING TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS
GENERAL CHILDCARE HAS SEEN
MINIMAL EXPANSIONS AND
INCREASES OVER PREVIOUS YEARS.
IN FACT THERE ARE SOME COUNTIES
IN THE STATE THAT HAVE NO
GENERAL CHUKAR CONTRACTS
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN AND AGENCIES THAT
CONCERNS THAT SHOULDER AND- WE
WOULD RECOMMEND AN INCREASE TO
DIRECT CONTRACTING TITLE FIVE
SHE'S TEACH OUR FUNDS FOR
CENTERS AND FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOME EDUCATION NETWORKS. IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET YEAR
THERE WAS AN EXPANSION OF FIFTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO
START A LITTLE OVER THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION RECEIVED REQUESTS IN
EXCESS OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
SIGNS THAT IS A HUNDRED AND 50%
DEMAND OVER THE FUNDS THAT WERE
ABLE TO BE ALLOCATED- GRAMS OR
STOP. IN THEIR TO GO THEY JUST
NEED THE FUNDS TO PROVIDE CARE
TO THE CHILDREN. ADDITIONALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO- RECOMMEND
ALLOWING CHILDREN TO REMAIN IN
THEIR SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
SPACES THE FIRST YEAR BEFORE
KINDERGARTEN SHOULD A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN REQUESTS THAT. WE KNOW
THAT CURRENTLY THERE IS A BIG
PUSH FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. HOWEVER THESE
PROGRAMS DO NOT ALWAYS WORK FOR
WORKING FAMILIES WE KNOW THAT
THESE PROGRAMS OPERATE ON A
SCHOOL YEAR OR SCHOOL DAY
SCHEDULE SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE IN CERTAIN AREAS AS
WE HEARD FROM OUR PARENTS
EARLIER TODAY. WE DO NOT WANT
WORKING FAMILIES TO LOSE THEIR
FULL TIME FULL YEAR SUBSIDIZED
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. AND HAVE TO BE MOVED
INTO THESE OTHER. PROGRAMS AND
LOSE THEIR PLACEMENT. LASTLY I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
HAVE LOST SO MANY CHILD CARE
FACILITIES JUST ILLUSTRATED IN
YOUR DOCUMENT OVER THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED FACILITIES HAVE
PERMANENTLY CLOSED SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. THIS IS A
COMBINATION OF CENTER BASED
FACILITIES AND FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOMES. NOW IS THE TIME TO
INVEST IN FACILITIES AS YOU
EXPAND ACCESS CONSIDER
EXPANDING FACILITY FUNDS SO
THAT OTHER CONTRACTING CENTER
BASED AGENCIES CAN TAKE OVER
THE LEASES ARE GETTING TO THE
PROPERTY OF THESE CLOSED
PROGRAMS BEFORE THEY ARE
RENOVATED OR CHANGED
COMPLETELY. THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT USE OF ONE TIME ONLY
FINES. ADDITIONALLY CROSS FOR
PROVIDERS ON FACILITY
IMPROVEMENTS MANY PROGRAMS HAVE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I NEED
FUNDS TO EXPAND THEIR PROGRAMS
TO SERVE MORE CHILDREN
INCLUDING INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION
OF THESE REQUESTS AND IDEAS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING TODAY AHEAD OF
THEM YOU MAY REALIZE. NOW IS
THE PERFECT TIME TO INVEST IN
OUR CHILDREN THE EASY WORK
FORCE TO INCREASE RATES TO PAY
LIVABLE WAGES AND TO EXPAND
ACCESS FOR MIXED DELIVERY
SYSTEM. DIRECT CONTRACTING
PROGRAMS AND VOUCHERS IT IS THE
TIME TO BUILD THE FOUNDATION
FOR EXCESS FAT AND INVEST IN
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION AND
CARE FOR THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU IN COMING MONTHS ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT SHARES.
THANK YOU VERY UCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE KIDS SHOULDN'T ZOO WE HOPE
WE ARE PRONOUNCED YOUR NAME
CORRECTLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL NETWORK. GOOD
AFTERNOON IT WAS CLOSE TO- MY
NAME IS QI ESSENCE THEY RE ON
THE PUBLIC POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK A
MEMBER AGENCY OF ALL OF THAT
SHOULD HAVE MOST OF THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
AGENCIES AND OUR STATE. MORE
THAN A YEAR AGO CHILD CARE WITH
THE CANARY IN THE COAL MINE.
WEEKS BEFORE FULL SHUTDOWN
BECAME A REALITY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ARE STRUGGLING TO
FIND CLEANING SUPPLIES AND
FOOD. THEY NEEDED TO CONTINUE
CARING FOR OUR CHILDREN. ALMOST
OVERNIGHT MANY CHILD CARE
CENTERS FOUND THEMSELVES FORCED
TO CLOSE. AS NEW COHORT
GUIDANCE PREVENTED THEM FROM
CARING FOR ENOUGH CHILDREN. TO
BE ABLE TO PAY STAFF. RENT AND
MORTGAGES. HOME BASED PROVIDERS
WERE AT COSTCO AND SAM'S CLUB
WITH THE REST OF US. TRYING TO
GET PAPER TOWELS TOILET PAPER.
AND CLEANING SPRAY. YEAH
PERSISTED. THE PANDEMIC HAS
BROUGHT OUT INTO THE OPEN. THE
WEAKNESSES OF OUR CHILD CARE
SYSTEM AND THE RESILIENCY OF
ITS WORK FORCE. DESPITE HIM
MORALLY LOW WAGES PAID TO CHILD
CARE WORKERS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO CARE FOR OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN WHEN ESSENTIAL WORKERS
NEEDED CARE OUR EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROFESSIONALS WITH THEIR-
TAKING ON THE RISK OF ILLNESS
OFTEN WITHOUT HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND DESPITE THE FRAGILE HEALTH
OF THEIR OWN FAMILY MEMBERS
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS FAMILIES
CHILDREN ALL EXPERIENCED A MASS
TRAUMA. CHILDREN LOSING PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS PROVIDERS
BECOMING ILL OR THEMSELVES
LOSING THEIR LIVES WE'VE ALL
BEEN THROUGH QUITE A YEAR.
TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS LOST A
THIRD OF ITS CHILD CARE CENTERS
AND 14% OF CHILD CARE HOMES BUT
IN SOME COUNTIES THOSE NUMBERS
ARE WELL OVER 50% PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AS I STATED BEFORE
CHILD CARE WAS ALREADY SCARCE.
AS GOVERNOR YOU SOME PROMISES
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WILL OPEN
JUNE FIFTEENTH WE ARE ALL RIGHT
FOR A RUDE AWAKENING. PARENTS
WHO KEPT THEIR CHILDREN HOME
THIS YEAR MAY FIND THE CARE
THEY KNEW AND LOVED IS GONE.
AND A NEW ONE WILL BE HARDER TO
FIND THAN EVER BEFORE.
ACCORDING TO THE UC BERKELEY
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF CHILD
CARE EMPLOYMENT. THE CHILD CARE
WORK FOR SHARKS 20% OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC. NO IT'S
NOT ONLY IMPERATIVE THAT WE
RAISE THE RATES AND WAGES FOR
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS. PROVIDE
ACCESS FOR ALL FAMILIES TO THE
CARE THEY NEED AND WANT BUT WE
ALSO MUST SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
WELL ESTABLISHED INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT IT'S BEEN THERE EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY TO SUPPORT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES
CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCIES. FOR MOST OF
US KNEW WHAT HIT US. ARE NICE
PIVOTED AND BECAME AMAZON
WAREHOUSES PROVIDED MUCH NEEDED
CLEANING SUPPLIES FOOD DIAPERS
TO CHILD PROVIDERS. PROVIDED
ONLINE PLAY GROUPS FOR FAMILY.
ALL MY PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAINING FOR PROVIDERS
SPREAD INFORMATION ABOUT KIKI
WILLEMS PPP ONCE OUR STATE
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS CONTINUE
TO RECRUIT AND TRAIN NEW
PROVIDERS AND RIGHT NOW
IMPORTANCE OF FILING YOUR TAXES
SO FAMILIES CAN RECEIVE THE
REFUNDABLE CHILD TAX CREDIT.
BUT LIKE SUPPORT FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS YOU FAMILIES THIS
PART OF OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM
HAS BEEN STARVED FOR DECADES
ALLOWING SO MANY ARE IN OUR
STAFF SPEND THEIR DAYS HELPING
FAMILIES FIND THE CARE THEY
NEED AND SUPPORTING PROVIDERS.
TO LANGUISH ON THE SAME
CHILDCARE WAITING LISTS AT
THOSE AT THOSE PARENTS TO HELP
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM. AT THIS
UNIQUE JUNCTURE IN OUR HISTORY
WE SHOULDN'T STRIVE TO COME
BACK TO NORMAL IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH I URGE YOU TO BE BOLDER
THAN YOU'VE EVER BEEN ALLOWED
TO BEFORE. FIND OUR ENTIRE
SYSTEM SO THAT FAMILIES CAN
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED AND
LOVE. CAREGIVERS CAN PROVIDE A
LOVING CARE WE ALL WANT FOR OUR
CHILDREN. WHILE STILL BEING
ABLE TO SUSTAIN THEIR FAMILIES
AND THE PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT THE
MALL CAN DRIVE AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. OUR
NEXT IS DENISE GOWER A PROVIDER
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DENISE
KELLER I'M A FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDER IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY.
I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
OVER FORTY THOUSAND FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
REPRESENTED BY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS UNITED CCPO. AS THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS APPEAR FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WE HOPE
THE FUTURE IN OUR HANDS EVERY
DAY. I AM HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
IF WE WANT THE FUTURE TO BE ONE
OF EQUITY PROSPERITY AND
PROMISE YOU NEED TO TAKE ACTION
RIGHT NOW TO FIX OUR BROKEN
CHILD CARE SYSTEM. I HAVE BEEN
A PROVIDER FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS. THIS IS NOT WORK YOU DO
TO GET RICH HEY. THIS IS. YOU
DO IT BECAUSE IT IS YOUR
CALLING. I BELIEVE THAT PUTS
YOU WHERE YOU ARE NEEDED. MY
PURPOSE IS TO CARE FOR AND
EDUCATE OUR YOUTH. THE PANDEMIC
SHOWED EVERYONE HOW IMPORTANT
WE ARE. WE PUT OUR LIVES ON THE
LINE TO KEEP THE ECONOMY GOING.
BUT THE SACRIFICES WE MADE FOR
REWARDED WITH HARDSHIPS. ON
MARCH SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
I HAD FOURTEEN CHILDREN
ENROLLED AND FOR EMPLOYEES. MY
CHAPTER WAS SMALL BUT THRIVING.
AND I HAD IT GENERATED A GROSS
INCOME OF OVER SIX FIGURES AND
TWENTY NINETEEN. IN THE
PANDEMIC FORCED US TO CLOSE FOR
SIX MONTHS. THE FAMILIES THAT I
SERVE ALSO THROWN INTO CHAOS.
SOME COULDN'T WORK SOME RELIED
ON FAMILY MEMBERS. I WENT FROM
HAVING A NICE SAVINGS AND A
FLOURISHING BUSINESS TO HAVING
TO ASK MY FATHER FOR MONEY TO
PAY MY RENT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MY LIFE. I HAVE SPENT
EVERYTHING I HAD TRYING TO
SURVIVE. I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
INDEPENDENT TO NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT MYSELF WAS DRAMATIC AND
I FELT HELPLESS. THE PANDEMIC
FLATLINE SO MANY OF US OVER SIX
THOUSAND FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS CLOSED BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC. AND MANY ARE NOT
COMING BACK. BEING A FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDER IS A CAREER
THIS IS OUR PROFESSION. OUR
BUSINESS SHOULD NOT BE
CONTINGENT UPON THE SEASON WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO WEATHER
THINGS LIKE A PANDEMIC.AND
STILL BE THERE WHEN IT'S OVER
TO SERVE THE FAMILIES THAT RELY
ON US. BUT WE RELY ON A VERY
THIN MARGIN THAT LEAVES US
VULNERABLE WHEN THE CRISIS HIT.
CONSIDER THIS THE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM PAYS TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT DOLLARS A WEEK
FOR NON FAT. MOST PARENTS WORK
FORTY HOURS WITH TRAVEL TIME
THEIR CHILDREN WILL BE WITH ME
FOR FIFTY HOURS A WEEK. DIVIDE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
BY FIFTY AND IT COMES TO FIVE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY SIX CENTS AN
HOUR AND THAT'S BEFORE I HAD
PAID FOR ANY EXPENSES THAT IT
COST ME. TO CARE FOR A BABY.
BABIES ARE WORTH MORE THAN FIVE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY SIX AN HOUR.
HI I'M WORTH MORE THAN FIVE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR.
AND IT FOR NOT. WHAT DOES THAT
SAY ABOUT OUR SOCIETY. YES MY
WORK IS A LABOR OF LOVE BUT I
CAN'T PAY MY BILLS AND EXPENSES
WITH LOVE. WE NEED A STABLE
ROBUST HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING FOR
AT THE BARGAINING TABLE REAL
TARGETED INVESTMENTS THAT
RETAIN AND ATTRACT THE MOST
TALENTED AND DEDICATED EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROFESSIONALS TO
DO THIS WORK. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT PROVIDERS LIKE ME HAVE
ACCESS TO BENEFITS LIKE. HEALTH
AND DENTAL CARE AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION. AND WE NEED WILL
RETIREMENT SECURITY AS IT IS
NOW I DON'T SEE HOW I WILL BE
ABLE TO RETIRE AT SIXTY FIVE.
OR EVER. WE ARE ALSO BARGAINING
TO MAKE QUALITY CHILD CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE SO THAT ALL THE
CHILDREN HAVE A CHANCE TO
SUCCEED REGARDLESS OF RACE
INCOME OR WHERE THEY LIVE. THAT
MEANS FINDING VOUCHERS FOR THE
MORE THAN ONE MILLION ZERO TO
THREE YEAR OLDS WHO QUALIFY AND
FOR EXPANDING CARE TWO EVENINGS
AND WEEKENDS. WE ALSO WANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO STREAMLINE HOW
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE SYSTEM
WORKS BY IMPROVING
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN ALL
PARTIES AND ORGANIZATIONS SO
THAT EVERYONE RECEIVES THE SAME
INFORMATION REGARDING STATE
POLICIES. WE DO APPRECIATE WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE SO
FAR TO IMPROVE CHILD CARE. BUT
THERE IS MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. WE ARE ASKING FOR AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE IS THAT THE
STATE GIVE US SECURITY AND
PEACE OF MIND SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRECIOUS
ASSETS. OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME. THANK YOU REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS-
THEY'RE VERY HELPFUL AND- AMONG
THE LAST OF OUR PANELISTS NOT
THE LEAST IS ANGIE GARLAND.
FROM THE LOW INCOME INVESTMENT
FUND WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR HAVING. I'M
ANTI RIGHT LEFT WE ARE A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION FINANCE. RESISTANCE
ABOUT HOUSING AND BUILDING
SHOCKER CELLS SOMETIMES YEAH.
SHE'S AT. ME RESPONDED BY
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT. SPORTS AND
IT'S NOT WRITERS AND SOME
CENTERS AND HELP OPERATORS.
BANK WORKING IN THE SPACE OF A
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
AMBASSADOR MANAGE THIS. YES AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT.
THIS IS A SPACE. SERVICE
FACILITIES ARE OFTEN
CONSIDERED- TEACHER. NOT JUST
THE TEACHER NOT JUST YEARS BUT
WHEN BAYERN THAT SUPPORTS
CHILDREN AND PROVIDE. SPACES AS
WELL AS OUR OWN SAFETY FACTORS
LIKE VENTILATION J. O. AND IT
ALSO PROVIDES A BREATHABLE
WORKPLACE BENEFITS EARLY STOP
ASKING US. BACK A GREAT PLACE.
TO WORK AS WELL AS H. AS OUR
HOUSTON VERSUS THAT WHILE
DOCTOR SUCH SPIKE THE- THANK.
RIGHT EXACERBATE EXACERBATED IT
YEAH THOUSANDS OF SOLDIERS.
JUST ONE DATA POINT IN THIS
STATE LESS THAN 10% OF ELIGIBLE.
FARMERS ACTUALLY. THANKS SIR
BUT THE NEED IS IT'S A ONE
HUNDRED SPOT BASS. AND NOT JUST
WORK FORCE AND THE STRUCTURE TO
ENSURE THE BEST TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS AND PROVIDERS BUT WE
ALSO NEED A SERVICE AND
PHYSICAL STRUCTURE. WE
APPRECIATE THE SENSE OF
COMMITMENT SOON SOME SAY SINCE
THEN SOME OF THE SMALL PART OF.
AND SO WHAT KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS RIGHT IT ALSO MEANS
IT'S A CRITICAL PIECE OF
CONSTRUCTION. IT IS JUST AS
ESSENTIAL AS ROADS AND BRIDGES.
ARE FOR FAMILIES TO GET TO WORK
AT A BARRIER IS THAT THERE IS
NO MONEY OUT OF THE STATE OR
FEDERAL LEVELS. PLEASE
PROVIDERS DON'T PLAN FOR WAR IN
HISTORY UNLESS THE NUMBER SIGN.
SO IT COULD TAKE TIME TO
DEVELOP A PIPELINE PROJECT.
WHEN ARE. WE THANK APPLE. THANK
THE ONLY SPENDING MUST INCLUDE
CENTERS AS WELL AS DAMAGE OUT
THERE. BECAUSE WE NEED TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE AXLES ASK ME
ABOUT THE PROBATION SERVICE.
OUR EXAMPLE LIVE THE PRODUCTS
ABOUT SUPPORT AND SHOCK WINDS
START UP GRANTS EXPANSION
GRANTS. SO THE PRODUCTS
AVAILABLE THE STOCK WAS. SOLD A
SOURCE OF WATER WHAT ARE THINGS
ARE PROVIDERS OTHERWISE STAND.
SO THEY DID THINGS LIKE INFO
SEPTEMBER WHICH- IT'S CONVERTED
BACKYARD SPACE TO MOVE AROUND
OUTSIDE SEVEN HOURS. APPLIANCES
LIKE WASHERS DRYERS THAT WAY
BECAUSE OF INCREASED NEWS. AND
THEN I ALSO NEED VERY IMPORTANT
MESSAGE FOX NEWS AND JUST WANTS
TO GET GRANTS BACK. ALL DURING
THE SMALL DEMOCRATS INCREASE ON
SOCIAL ASSISTANCE SO WE WILL
NEED ADDITIONAL FACILITIES
FUNDING TO BUILD A SERVICE.
ASKED AN EXAMPLE WE OFTEN
ALLOCATE OR THINK THAT FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO START BUT-
FOR CENTRE. BACK CHILDREN BUT
WE ALSO JUST FINANCE CENTER IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAT WAS A
STANDALONE CENTER THAT SHE-
WON'T GET OUT STEP BACK. THIS
IS NOT WHAT SHE- FINALLY I'M
SURE THIS SUMMER FOR HER IT WAS
RECOMMENDED AND THEN ANOTHER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS RESTORATION EXISTING.
FINANCE THAT WAS ZEROED OUT.
AND BASED ON SOME COST OWN
THANK YOU FOR HER THAT'S ACROSS
TO MEET ALL THESE NEEDS IT'S
ACTUALLY. SENSIBLE THIS IS A
GREAT. INITIAL REQUEST. THESE
ARE GREAT USE OF ONE TIME MONEY.
AND I GOT ALL MY IS. ACTUALLY
ALLOWED IN I LOVE HOME AND
CERTAIN SOME OF THE STIMULUS
SPENDING AND MORE FEDERAL.
FUNDS BUT THIS IS NOT ENOUGH HE
NEEDS TO HELP. ENSURE THAT NEED
BACKSTAGE MONEY. FEDERAL MONEY
CAMPBELL. OPERATIVELY THAT.
HELPS STATES UNDERSTAND OUR
FEDERAL THE MONEY IS FOR. THIS
IS JUST PART OF THE SOLUTION S.
RIGHT YEAH FIVE HELP LEVERAGE
PUBLIC FUNDING PACKAGE SIGNING
SO THE PUBLIC FUNDING IS ONLY
PART OF THE SOLUTION THIS IS
IMPORTANT IN ORDER TO MAKE
FEDERAL AND STATE DOLLARS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME ENGINE
FOR SEVEN SORRY AS ONE. OF ITS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SO THAT COMPLETES THE
PRESENTATIONS OF THE. EIGHT
PANELISTS WE HAD ON THIS ITEM.
A LET ME JUST SAY I HAVE SOME
QUESTION BUT I'M GOING TO GO IN
A SECOND TO SEE IF THE
COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE QUESTIONS
FIRST. BUT IT SEEMS THAT
ANYTHING I WAS THINKING OF
ASKING GOT COVERED IN SOME WAY
IN THIS AND IT'S ONLY A
QUESTION IN MY VIEW OF DRAWING
OUT SOME OF THE PANELISTS AND-
OR MAYBE ALLOWING A FEW OF THE
OTHERS TO RESPOND TO OTHERS AND
SO- AND I KNOW WE HAVE FIFTEEN
PANELISTS ON THE NEXT ITEM SO.
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE TIME IN
THE WORLD SO LET ME ASK.
COLLEAGUES IF PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE FIRM
CHAIR EIGHT MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR- AND I
WOULD AGREE I THOUGHT THE
PRESENTATIONS WERE- WELL DONE
AND CERTAINLY- OUTLINED I THINK
SOME OF THE PRIORITIES OF THE
SENATE'S. BILL BACK BOLDLY
BUDGET PLAN- CAN I SAY HELLO TO
MY CONSTITUENTS AND CHRISTINE
FIGUEROA I'VE KNOWN HER SINCE
BEFORE SHE WAS A MOM- IT WAS
NICE TO SEE HER AND- AND
HOPEFULLY THINGS ARE GOING
WELL- AND I GUESS IT JUST WON'T
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THIS. AND I
DON'T THINK WE CAN OVERSTATE
THE FACT THAT AS AS WE ALL WENT
INTO THIS PANDEMIC- FOR
CHILDCARE WORKERS WHO CONTINUE
TO DO THIS WORK DESPITE HUGE
DIFFICULTIES. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT- A LOT OF OUR CHILD CARE
WORKERS. AND SUBSTRATE SHALL
CARE ARE SOME OF THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO WERE IMPACTED THE
WORST MICHAEL WOULD TEND TO BE
PEOPLE WITH. AS KNOW WE
DON'T PAY VERY WELL LOWER
SOCIAL ECONOMIC- AS WELL AS
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY THOSE ALSO
IMPACTED BY. BY COVERT AND
HEALTH RELATED ISSUES SO- I
THINK IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
THAT WE BUILD OUR CHILD CARE
SYSTEM BACKED. UP SOME OF THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING GOING FOR
FACILITIES AT A POTENTIALLY
CLOSER OR HAVE NEEDED TO REHAB
IS IMPERATIVE. AND I GUESS THE
ONLY QUESTION I WOULD HAVE FOR
SOME OF THE PANELIST IS- AND I
THINK WE'RE ALL SUPPORTIVE OF
T. K. BUT NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF
OUR CHILD CARE SLOTS BECAUSE WE
KNOW. AS MUCH AS PEOPLE HAVE
POINTED OUT THAT THEY'RE NOT
JUST EIGHT TO FIVE DURING THE
DAY WHEN. SOMEONE'S GOING TO AN
OFFICE TO WORK BUT THEY ARE.
AROUND THE CLOCK AND ARE LOWER.
OR LOWER WAGE WORKERS ARE
SERVICE INDUSTRY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A CHILD HERE
SOMEWHERE. SO I GUESS I WOULD
JUST ASK HOW I KNEW THE
PANELISTS IF THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT. THEIR THINKING ABOUT
MORE CHILD CARE SLOTS VERSUS. A
UNIVERSAL T. K. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE THAT FIRST OKAY. ALSO
ALL STAR AND THEN I'M SURE NINA
WILL. JUMP IN AND I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND- I THINK WE
ARE ALL. CONCERNED THAT THIS IS
A REALLY CRITICAL TIMES FOR OUR
CHILD CARE SYSTEM. WHICH SERVES
ALL CHILDREN. ZERO THROUGH
TWELVE NOT JUST ONE AGE GROUP.
AND THAT WE KNOW THAT OUR
FAMILIES NEED CHOICE. AND
CALIFORNIA IS- LARGE DIVERSE
STATE. IT IS NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL STATE. AND I THINK
THAT CONCERNS MANY OF US HAVE
WITH THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROPOSAL. IS IT
TAKES THE PARENT CHOICE OUT.
AND GIVES THEM A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. SO I THINK THAT WE ALL
APPRECIATE THAT THE T. K.
SERVICES CAN BE PART OF A
BROADER PRESCHOOL SYSTEM
UNIVERSAL PRE SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
THE STATE. BUT IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A MIXED
A LIVERY MODEL AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OTHER STATES. THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SIMILAR PROGRAMS
THEY HAVE DONE IT. IN CONCERT
WITH. THEIR CHILD CARE SYSTEM
AND LIFTED UP THEIR CHILD CARE
SYSTEM RATHER THAN HELD IT DOWN
AND DIMINISHED IT. AND THAT
INCLUDED. CHILD CARE CENTER
FAMILY CHILD CARE AND ALSO OUR-
OUR FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS WHO'S BEEN FILLING A
GOOD DEAL OF THE GAP. DURING
THIS CRISIS SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THE CHILD
CARE PIECES RIGHT FIRST WE'VE
GOT TO GET COMPENSATION RATE
WERE FAR BEHIND ON PAYING
PEOPLE ADEQUATE WAGES. AND
SEQUENCING IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING AND HAVING A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN IS AN
IMPORTANT THING. SO THAT WE CAN
MEET ALL CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES WHERE THEY ARE AND
GIVE THEM CHOICES THAT BEST
MEET THEIR NEEDS. THANK YOU-
YES GO HEAD TO. FROM THE
PRINTER- I JUST WANTED TO ADD
ON TO- DONNA'S COMMENTS THE I
REALLY C. T. K. AS PART OF THE
SYSTEM THERE IS ONLY LIKE HEAD
START AS PART OF THE SYSTEM
STATE PRESCHOOL AS PART OF THE
SYSTEM AND ABOUT YOUR CARE
FIELD IS PART OF THE SYSTEM AS
WELL. WE CANNOT UNDER RESOURCE
ONE PART OF THE SYSTEM FOR
ANOTHER PART OF THE SYSTEM
THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE
CHOOSING TO K. ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FAMILIES SPEND
POTENTIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR HEAD START PROGRAM
DOES THAT ARE RECEIVING A
VOUCHER FOR A WEEKEND OR AFTER
HOURS CARE AND EQUALLY THOSE
THAT ARE RECEIVING A STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS. THE
PARENTAL CHOICE IS 1100% KEENEY
I'M AS WE LEARN FROM OUR
WONDERFUL FAMILIES TODAY WE CON
ASK THEM TO TRADE ONE FULL DAY
FULL YEAR PROGRAM FOR A SCHOOL
DAY SCHOOL YEAR PROGRAM IT'S
UNFAIR ASGHAR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES TO MAKE THAT CHOICE
IT'S- WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
ACCESS WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
WAITING LIST IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS A NEED TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO ALL OF OUR MIXED
DELIVERY SYSTEM AS WELL AS TO
HEAD START THERE ARE A LOT OF
FOUR YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE NEED THIS ENTIRE SYSTEM
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THEM ALL
SET FOR ME T. K. AS ONE PART OF
THE SYSTEM BUT THAT PARENTAL
CHOICE IS KEY BECAUSE AGAIN WE
CANNOT PUT THIS CHOICE BEFORE
FAMILIES AGAIN RISKING THEIR
FULL DAY FULL YEAR CARE FOR A
PARK. A SCHOOL YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU N. MARKET YOU OF YOUR
HAND. THAT EARLY HERE WHERE MY
CHILD FROM WHEN HE WAS. EVEN
SMALLER. HI. IT TOOK ME A LONG.
PROFESSIONS TO THEN GET ME THE
REFERRAL. DISTRICT AND THEN GET
ACCESS MEANT FOR HIM IT WAS
LIKE. ATTIC AND NINETEEN BY
THAT TIME I HAD MISSED ALREADY
SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES HE
COULD'VE BEEN GETTING SERVICES
FROM EARLY ON SO THEY SAID WELL
YOU KNOW WHAT IF WE CAN'T HELP
HIM ANYMORE BECAUSE HE'S NOW
THIS AGE AND ALL OF YOU WERE.
YOU KNOW SO. I THINK THAT
THERE'S A NEED FOR TKO PROGRAMS
AND I THINK IT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL FAMILIES FOR
ALL KIDS WHO NEEDED AN EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS. CAN BENEFIT.
FROM THIRD TO UP TO THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD EVEN CHILD KERR STOLE
CENTRAL BECAUSE- CHILD CARE IS
NOT A ONE SIZE. FITS ALL
SITUATION PARENTS WORKING. GET
TOLD. THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT BOTH OF THOSE WORK FOR ALL
FAMILIES TO KEEP FAMILIES
WORKING KEEP KIDS LEARNING IS
WHICH BRINGS THAT HAS KEPT WITH
ME AND I LOVED IT SO MUCH
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE. I THANK YOU
FOR THE SPACE. THANK YOU AND I
THINK WE CAN HEAR OTHER PEOPLE
LEARNING IN THE BACKGROUND
THERE SIR. I'M SORRY DON'T I
DON'T BE SORRY AT ALL IT IS
VERY THEMATIC WE APPRECIATE IT.
SENATOR MITCHELL SAID OR DID
THAT COMPLETE I THOUGHT THAT
COMPLETED YET THAT I JUST I
JUST WANT TO DO IS JUST TO SAY
FOR THE RECORD THAT WE KNOW THE
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAD
TO LEAVE THE WORK FORCE DURING
THIS PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN. HAVE
BEEN WOMEN AND WORKING WOMEN
AND WOMEN OF COLOR AND- WOMEN
WITH LOWER SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS
SO WE WANT EVERYONE TO GET BACK
TO WORK AND WE CERTAINLY DO.
THEN WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE CHILD CARE AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY IN ADDITION
TO. THE SENATE'S BILL BACK
PROBABLY AS A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WE
ALSO ASK FOR. IN THE TWO
HUNDRED SLOTS IN CHILDCARE AND
TO BE ABLE TO WAIVE FEES AND TO
RAISE REIMBURSEMENT RATES SO
THERE'S A LOT OF CONSISTENCY
AND NOT AND WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS
ASKED FOR AND- AT THE SENATE IN
OUR BILL BACK PULLED THE
PLANNING AND WE HOPE TO SEE
THESE THINGS COME TO FRUITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- CENTER MAN
AND THEN AFTERWARDS. I'M GONNA
GO TO CENTER OF TROUBLED. THANK
YOU VERY FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
REALLY APPRECIATE- BACK INSIDE.
I AND I THINK YOU'VE ALL
EMPHASIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRYING TO BUILD BACK BETTER ALL
OUR- CHILD CARE. SYSTEM AND THE
VARIOUS SUBSIDIES AND SUPPORTS
THAT ARE NECESSARY- A LOT OF
WORKING FAMILIES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT CRITICAL CHILD CARE
AND- AS A FATHER OF THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN MYSELF I. KNOW IT'S
BASICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO WORK
WITHOUT TOP CARE. PROPERTY
THESE DAYS WITH MOST FAMILIES
BEING EITHER SINGLE HOUSEHOLDS-
TWO WORKER HOUSEHOLDS- I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS. ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE EQUATION- YOU KNOW
I KNOW IN OTHER CONTEXTS. SOME
OF THE EMERGENCY RELIEF FOR
COVETED- PROGRAMS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND STATE. I
HAVE HAD DIFFICULTIES JUST LIKE
AS FAR AS PEOPLE UNDERSTANDING
AND BEING AWARE THAT THESE
EXIST PARTICULARLY-
COMMUNITIES. OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES HOUSEHOLDS WHERE
ENGLISH IS NOT THE FIRST
LANGUAGE- A DO WE HAVE A
SIMILAR POTENTIAL CHALLENGE
WITH WITH. JUST MAKING PARENTS
AWARE. OF SOME OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE TO THEM IS THAT
IT'S- SOMETHING YOU GUYS HAVE
SEEN OR IS THAT. IT REALLY JUST
EVERYBODY NEEDS CHILD CARE SO
IT'S NOT REALLY CONCERNED I
JUST LOVE TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT. WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
ON THE GROUND ARE YOU DIRECTING
THAT QUESTION TO SOMEONE OR IS
IT EVERYONE FOR THEMSELVES. I
THINK THAT QUESTION BE DIRECTED
TO LA- AND THEN ANY OF THE-
OTHER CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ARE
POLICY GROUPS OUT THERE THAT
MIGHT HAVE A PERSPECTIVE. ON
THIS THANK YOU MISS CORTES. YES
THANK YOU I SEE THAT MR
INTEREST WANTS TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION SO I'LL CHECK I'LL
TAKE THE FIRST STEP AND THEN-
ONE OF THE THINGS I JUST LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT- J. P.
AGENCIES ADDRESS CONTRACT
PROVIDERS DO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE VERY LONG WAITING LISTS-
SO. I THINK THE WAY IT WORKS ON
THE GROUND FROM- FROM WHAT I'VE
HEARD IS THAT FAMILIES ARE KIND
OF ARE AWARE- OF THE CHILD CARE
SERVICES GO TO AN H. P. AGENCY-
OR GO TO THE DIRECT CONTRACTOR
DIRECTLY WHICH IT COULD BE A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR A- OR A
LOCAL. ORGANIZATION BUT I'M
SURE MY SURGERY CAN COME. OUT
ON SET ON TO THEM. THANK YOU.
S. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR I DEAD CHILD
CARE. LOCAL CHILDCARE AGENCY IS
THAT SOMETIMES ARE REFERRED TO
AS RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
AGENCIES. SOMETIMES AS AGE HE
IS- OFTEN WE ARE BOTH IN THE
SAME. OUR PRIMARY JOB IS TO
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT CHILD
CARE AND THAT HAPPENS THROUGH.
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
MODALITIES WHETHER THAT'S ON
THE TELEPHONE. LINE OR- THROUGH
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT IN BANDS. OFTEN
PARENTS FIND US THROUGH A CHILD
CARE PROVIDER BECAUSE THE
PROVIDERS FALL. OR IF THEY NEED
ASSISTANCE WITH PAYMENT- I AND
I DO KNOW THAT AS THESE
PROGRAMS TRANSITION TO
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THERE ARE. PLANS AND HOPEFULLY
PLANS WITH SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS THIS YEAR. TO BUILD
OUT THAT- LOCAL COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH RESOURCE
CENTER FOR ALL. TO EXPAND THAT
REACH- EXPAND THAT REACH ON
SOCIAL MEDIA EXPAND THAT REACH
ALL THE PLACES PARENTS ARE. ARE
PART OF OUR CHARGE- AS THESELOCAL CHILDCARE AGENCIES IS TO
BE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY WHICH
HAS BEEN A LITTLE DIFFICULT.
WITH THE PANDEMIC BUT WE REALLY
HAVE RESPONDED BY BEING
AVAILABLE WITH FOOD AND
SUPPLIES AND ALL THE THINGS.
THAT MY COLLEAGUE CATION
BROUGHT. A ALSO DO AS- ABOUT
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
FAMILIES MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
WHETHER THAT IS A HEAD START
PROGRAM A STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. AND WE REALLY
WORK WITH THE FAMILY TO CREATE
A PLAN THAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
SECOND PLEASE YOUR QUESTION
THEN LET'S GO TO SANDRA CHART
BOOK. THANK YOU MR CHAIR.
RUSSIAN S. TO THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE AND HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST
TO BRING THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
FOR PROVIDERS UP TO THE MOST
RECENT SURVEY. WHICH I BELIEVE
WAS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND I BELIEVE DO WE EVER
COMPLETE A TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY OUR SURVEY OR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WHERE'S THE
WHERE'S THE PLAN ON THAT AND-
BURN UPDATED SURVEY. THE THIRD
GRADE WITH THE LA L. SO THERE
WAS NOTHING TO DO WITH TWENTY
TWENTY SURVEY ON MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WAS DELAYED
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC SO IT WAS.
DELAYED A LITTLE BIT- SO THERE
WILL BE A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SURVEYS MIGHT MY EXISTING
UNDERSTANDING. COME IN TERMS OF
MOVING THE CAR THE COST OF
MOVING TO THE MOST RECENT-
REGIONAL MARKET RATE- AND
SHOULD HAVE THE COST OF A- I'M-
I'M- I'M TRYING TO FIND IT IN
MY FILES IN THIS MOMENT WHICH
IS PROBABLY NOT A GREAT. GREAT
IDEA- BUT I GUESS IT. WOULD
DEPEND ON WHAT KIND OF. WHAT
KIND OF PERSON HOW YOU WANT TO
GO TO SO THAT'S KIND OF. I'M
TOO TO INCREASE RATE- YOU CAN
MOVE TO THE MOST RECENT
SURVEYING KEEP AT THE SEVENTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE- BUT THERE'S
ALSO I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT SOME
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGE TO
MOVE G. EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE
SO THAT WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
COST TO JUST MOVING TO THE MOST
RECENT SURVEY. AND THEY'RE ALL
JUST HOP IN AND I BELIEVE THAT
YOUR ESTIMATES FOR THE SEVENTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE. OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SURVEY WERE JUST SHY
OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
OBVIOUSLY MOVING UP TO THE
EIGHTY FIFTH WOULD BE SLIGHTLY
HIGHER. AND THEN- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RATE REFORM
OVER TIME WOULD MOVE ALL
PROVIDERS- THAT INTO A HIGHER
CATEGORY. SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
LEVERS AT PLAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I DID I DID- I
DID. EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MOVING TO THE 70%
OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SURVEY
WOULD COST TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION- AND
MOVING TO THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SURVEY IT'S FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION AND THAT'S NOT
INCLUDING HIM IN THE RIGHT
REFORM HE SAYS NOT JUST
INCLUDING- AFTER DOCTOR SIDE-
OF. THESE PROGRAMS. SO TO. SUM
I WAS JUST GOING TO ADD MY
APOLOGIES AND SO I MEAN I'M
PRETTY AGAIN SO THAT WOULD BE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE VOUCHER
SIDE OF THE PROGRAM IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT RATE REFORM AND
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE OFF THE
DIRECT CONTRACTING PROGRAMS
TRUE THAT. EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE THAT WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL FINES THAT WE WOULD
ESTIMATE AROUND THREE HUNDRED
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
ADDITIONALLY TO GET THEM UP TO
THAT LEVEL AS WELL BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE ONES SUBSIDIZED AT THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
WHICH IS A SINGLE. RATE ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SANDRA TROUBLE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR SURGES. AND THIS
IS TO THE EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENTILE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN- ON. SURVEYS THAT
CORRECT. YES THAT IS CORRECT
THAT IS CORRECT SO A TOTAL OF.
ALMOST A BILLION TO GET IT UP
TO PAR. AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT
I'M GOING TO ASSUME I'M
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY WHAT I.
RECALL FROM OUR PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION IS THAT IN ORDER
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS END AND
MAKE IT STANDARD- WE WOULD HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT IN
STATUTE- THE AUTOMATIC
INCREASES TO THESE FEES MOVING
FORWARD. IS THAT CORRECT. WHO'S
YOUR QUESTION DIRECTED TO THE I
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE OKAY
THANK YOU. YES SO CURRENTLY IN
STATUTE RUNS THE LEGISLATURE
SETS THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S A TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SURVEY WERE STILL AT THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURVEYS ABOUT STATUTORY
CHANGE TO MOVE INTO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SURVEY SO ANOTHER WAY
TO GO ABOUT IT WOULD BE AT THE
SUGGESTION. TO MAKE IT
AUTOMATIC SO WHENEVER THERE'S A
NEW SURVEY- THERE THERE COULD
BE THERE COULD BE INCREASES-
THE USING THAT WOULD BE
AUTOMATIC THAT. CHILD. CARE
PROVIDERS WOULD USE SETTING
SPRAY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND
THEN ONE LAST QUESTION AND- AND
THIS IS. A LEAVE THAT UP TO THE
CHAIR TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
ANSWER AT THIS TIME BUT- IF WE
CAN GET IT UPDATED- THE
TRANSFER OF STATE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
CALIFORNIA PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
FROM THE C. D. E. TO THE D. S.
S. AND WHO YOU ARE ASKING. FOR-
ARE YOU ASKING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST TO GIVE YOU THAT
UPDATE- GOOD QUESTION YES PRINT
I AM HAPPY TO HAPPY TO GIVE
THAT UPDATE SO THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES I'M TRANSITIONING
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS FROM SEED TO
CVS- AND SO THIS IS A CHEF SO
THERE'S GOING TO COST NEUTRAL
COMPONENTS OF THIS- THIS PIECE
AND PART OF IT AND IT'S THE
FIRST COMPONENT IS THAT IT'S A
COST NEUTRAL SHIFT OF
OBSTRUCTING THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUND SO IT'S ABOUT.
THREE BILLION- SHIFTING FROM
SEED TO CDS OF CRIMES THAT ARE
GOING TO GO TO LOCALS TO
PROVIDE SHELTER SERVICES BUT
ALSO ADD THAT IF THERE'S ALSO A
NUTRITION PROGRAM- ADDED TO THE
LIST THEN THE OTHER PIECE IS
THE OPERATIONS SO ALL OF THE
STAFFING OF THE STATE. AND LET
ME JUST MAYBE INTERVENE FOR
SECOND BECAUSE WE HAD A HEARING
ON THIS AND I SUSPECTED
DISSENTERS ASKING FOR JUST
CURRENT UPDATE OUT TO JUST KNOW
THE STATUS OF HOW THAT.
TRANSITION IS HAPPENING. SO IT.
ARE DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT YOU
NEED GIVE IT NOW NEED YOU
SHOULD PROVIDE IT TO THE
SENATOR AND THEN COPY ALL OF US
ON THE COMMITTEE'S. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR TROUBLE DID THAT-
COMPLETE YOUR QUESTIONING- YES
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN.
I'M JUST GONNA RATHER THAN ASK
MORE QUESTIONS. JUST MAKE A
BRIEF STATEMENT BECAUSE- I.
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUE FOR LONGER THAN I CARE TO
ADMIT- AS A COUNTY PERSON.
CHOIR FOR OVER FORTY YEARS AGO
WE REALLY DID STUDIES AND
EXPANDED CARE AND HAD SOME OF
THE FIRST TODDLER CARE. AND IT
HAS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER THAT
FUNDED AS THE CHAIR OF THE
LOCAL CHILD CARE COUNCIL. AND
EVEN THOUGH WE MADE PROGRESS
BECAUSE THERE WERE DISHED OUT
PROGRAMS THAT CAME FROM THE
STATE FOR DIGITAL ABILITIES
AND- AND SOMETIMES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD GET IN WHERE
THEY HADN'T BEEN IN BEFORE AND
OTHER THINGS. SOME OF THE BASIC
ISSUES JUST REMAIN THE SAME
WHETHER PAYING WORKERS
ENOUGH WHETHER THRE ARE ENOUGH
SLOTS WHETHER THERE'S TODDLER
CARE. OF WHETHER THIS
INTEGRATES BETWEEN ALL THE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS
IN A GOOD WAY. THOSE STILL
EXIST I THINK WE HEARD FROM OUR
EIGHT PANELISTS EXACTLY THAT
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT SENDER
AIKMAN WAS SAYING FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE MIGHT HAVE A CHANCE TO
REALLY DO ONE BIG SIGNIFICANT
THING ABOUT IT IT WANTS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS PROPOSAL IS.
THAT AND SO I THINK THAT'S WHY
I SEE HEADS NODDING AND PEOPLE
FEELING LIKE. A WE WANNA TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY OF HAVING THIS
MONEY AVAILABLE TO TRY TO JUMP
THESE THINGS UP TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCESO- THAT'S WHY
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY THAT
TESTIFIED TODAY I APPRECIATE
THE PROPOSAL THAT'S COMING FROM
THE SENATE. AND I AM CURIOUS TO
SEE WHAT'S IN THE MAY REVISE IT
WHEN WE GET INTO THE FINE
DETAIL. AND THEN I THINK IT'S
OUROBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE WE
DO MOVE AHEAD IN ORDER FOR THE
ACTIONS. OF SO WITH THAT. OUR
GOING TO MOVE TO A NUMBER. BUT
WHEN WE TO ISSUE NUMBER. A
CENTER EIGHT MINUTES GOING TO
CHAIR THIS PART OF THE HEARING
SO. I'M GOING TO GIVE HER THE
GAVEL AND SHE CAN HANDLE THE
UNRULY PEOPLE- WELL THIS IS
GOING ON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CURE LAYERED OKAY NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE WHICH HAS TO DO WITH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OKAY
AND ISSUE NUMBER ONE- IT'S A
PACKAGE OF THE SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSALS IN
WE HEARD THESE IN JANUARY. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THE LA- WANTS TO
SAY ANYTHING AT THIS TIME BUT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO ASK-
DIRECTLY MAYBE WE- WILL LIVE
BORN HAD TO BE DOING IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE US ANY KIND
OF UPDATE ON THESE THREE. THESE
THREE PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN AFTER
THAT WILL WE WILL BE IF THEY
SEE WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY TO US
AND THEN AFTER THAT WE WILL
FOLLOW- WITH SOME PANELISTS TO
SPEAK TO SOME OF THESE SPECIFIC
ISSUES- HELLO DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO START WITH. THANK
YOU SENATOR ECONOMIC. ISSUE TO
WITH THE LMAO- WE AS AS HE
NOTED YOU KNOW WE RODE UP-
THESE PROPOSALS IN JANUARY
DON'T DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
SORT OF FURTHER COMMENTS TO ADD
ON TOP OF WHAT WE RODE UP IN
JANUARY- JUST TO SORT OF
REITERATE- YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR
COMMENTS FROM- JANUARY VERY
VERY BRIEFLY- ON THE- TWO
PROPOSALS FOR- FUNDING THROUGH
THE- METAL STUDENT SERVICES
ACT. AND THE PROBLEM MANY
EIGHT- THE FUNDS WE ARE
RECOMMENDING REJECTION OF THE-
NINETY EIGHT COMPONENT OF THAT
BUT APPROVAL OF THE- AC
PORTION. AND THEN FOR THE US.
SERVICES THROUGH MANAGED CARE
PLANS- WE WOULD JUST SORT OF
NOTE THAT- ARE OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS ABOUT SORT OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- INTO SEASON
AND BY A LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES I'M STILL STAND WITHIN
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE. QUITE
A SIGNIFICANT LIFT IN THAT
COORDINATION IS REALLY GOING TO
HAVE TO BE- A CENTRAL THEME OF
THIS OF THIS PROPOSAL GOING
FORWARD SO. THOSE ARE JUST OUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- AND I GUESS IT JUST IT
JUST BEAR SAYING AS WHAT WE'RE
ALL SITTING HERE RIGHT NOW I'M
LOOKING AT THESE THREE CONCRETE
PROPOSALS THAT WE HEARD ABOUT.
IN IN JANUARY AND EARLIER IN
THE YEAR. THAT YESTERDAY THE
ADMINISTRATION MADE SOME PRETTY
BIG ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT SOME
NEW PROGRAMS ARE COMING ON
BOARD- AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OF THAT OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
HERE TO HAVE ANY COMMENTS
ABOUT. AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY OF THESE IF THESE
NEW INITIATIVES- THERE'S YET.
ANOTHER UNKNOWN KIND OF
INITIATIVE OUT THERE AND WE AND
WE ARE VERY CURIOUS ABOUT HOW
ALL THESE THINGS ARE GONNA WORK
TOGETHER- AND I WERE WONDERING
IF YOU CAN GET A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION ON THAT TODAY. DO
EVERYTHING FIRST THE HELLO.
JUST TO SORT OF MENTIONED ABOUT
KOREA SHE DAILY- JUST TO SORT
OF MENTIONED THAT- WEEK WE ARE
SORT OF IN THE PROCESS OF
STARTING OR MAYBE VISOR HE WENT
ON WHAT WILL PROBABLY HAVE
FURTHER COMMENTS ON- THE
GOVERNOR'S NEW PROPOSED-
INITIATIVES YESTERDAY AT AT
RELATIVELY SHORT LATER TIME BUT
JUST THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAVE A DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
BEILEIN ARE ALMOST UPON A
FINANCE- SO WE WOULD SAY THAT
WE HAVE- ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR.
BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS. AVAILABLE FOR THIS
PROPOSAL. R. WHICH INCLUDES.
SOME FUNDING FROM OUR BUS LINES
AND ALSO SOME. UP FEDERAL FUNDS
AS WELL. AND WE CAN GIVE MORE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY WHAT
THAT INCLUDES I WOULD DEFER TO
MY COUNTERPARTS AND DICTATES
THE OUTSIDE. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELL WE ARE WE ARE
VERY EAGER TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THAT AND AGAIN HOW ALL OF THESE
NEW PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO
INTERSECT TOGETHER- AND WE'VE
HEARD WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
SOMETIMES A CONFUSION. OF
MULTIPLE PAYMENT SOURCES COMING
INTO A SYSTEM AND SO OUR GOAL
IS ALWAYS TO MAKE THAT THAT
EASIER NOT MORE DIFFICULT SO-
WILL BE WILL BE EAGER TO HEAR
MORE I GUESS NOW WE'LL TURN TO
THEN- MR LIKE PORN. DO YOU
WANNA DO YOU WANNA TAKE US
THROUGH THIS. GERMAN STOCK WILL.
HELLO I THINK YOU'RE A MUTED OR
SOMEBODY CAN I MEET YOU. WE ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SCHERING WHEN
TRAVELER MANY MEMBERS WILL LIKE
ONE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND I'M JOINED BY
J. C. COOPER WHOSE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IN OUR STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR. COLUMN LONG STANDING
CONCERN ABOUT THE NEED TO
INCREASE MEDICAL SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM. HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
EDUCATIONAL OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE SP SEVENTY FIVE
WORKGROUP. ALL PROGRAMS TO
IDENTIFY WAYS TO BETTER
LEVERAGE MEDI CAL. THAT WORK
CONTINUES IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
MISSING ELEMENT HAS BEEN REALLY
THE LARGEST CARD THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM WHICH S MANAGED CARE.
WHICH IS ALREADY PAID TO
PROVIDE PHYSICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. 85% OF THE
NEARLY FOURTEEN MILLION PEOPLE
WE COVER. IT IS CAROLINE'S ARE
MINIMALLY CONNECTED UP A LITTLE
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM DESPITE THE
FACT THAT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
STUDENTS THERE ARE ALREADY
COVERED BY. THE PROPOSAL WE
ADVANCED IN JANUARY IS DESIGNED
TO PERMANENTLY REMEDY THAT.
CHRIS COOPER WILL ELABORATE ON
THAT IN A MOMENT. OF COURSE IS
EVERYTHING AND AS SHE
REFERENCED. THE GOVERNOR AND
SECRETARY PREVIEWED A PROPOSAL
YESTERDAY FOR LEASING MOMENTUM
REVISION TOMORROW TO DEVELOP A
PAIR OF GNOSTIC SYSTEM
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. FOR
CHILDREN IN HOUSTON CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THAT ENGLISH WILL BE
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE PROPOSAL
ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY. JANUARY
PROPOSAL REMAINS A CENTRAL.
STAYING ABILITY OF SCHOOL BASED
SERVICES GOING FORWARD SO. THAT
IS A PRACTICE AND LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO A MISS COOPER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WELL. SO WHAT
ARE I WILL I'LL FIRST ADDRESS
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS REGARDING
THAT STUDENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES A PROPOSAL THAT IS ON
YOUR AGENDA TODAY I'M SO AS
WELL MENTIONED SENSE WE'VE
PREVIOUSLY PRESENTED ON THIS
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN MEETING WITH A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO THAT THE
PROPOSAL FIND YOUR NICHE AND
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT IT IS SUCCESSFUL
FOR ALL ENTITIES INVOLVED. I WE
HAVE MET WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MULTIPLE TIMES WE'VE
MET WITH MANY MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
EXISTING AND OR PLANNED OUR
RELATIONSHIPS- AND IT AN
EXPANDED SERVICES IN THAT SPACE
WE'VE MET WITH A NUMBER OF
EDUCATION ADVOCATES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEN OF COURSE
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS WITH S. U.
V. H. D. A. AND OTHERS. TO
LEARN NOT ONLY WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURES THERE TODAY AND
HOW WE CAN BUILD OFF OF IT- AND
YOU HAVE A GROW BUT HOW WE CAN
LINK OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS
COUNTY PARTNERS AND SCHOOL
PARTNERS TOGETHER IN THE FUTURE
TO MAKE THE PROPOSAL AS
SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE. ARE THE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE REALLY TALKED
ABOUT WHAT IS NEEDED FROM A
PLANNING AND COORDINATION POINT
OF VIEW OF WHERE THEIR GAPS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE
INCENTIVES COULD FUND I'M AS
WELL AS EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE
EARLY PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION SERVICES WHERE
THOSE EXIST WHERE THERE'S STILL
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT WE CAN
FINE TUNE THE INCENTIVE PACKAGE
FOR THE FUTURE. ADDITIONALLY WE
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DID DEVELOPED AND
RELEASED A FACT SHEET RELATED
TO THE PROPOSAL THAT WAS
RELEASED ON APRIL SIXTEENTH AND
IF YOU HAVE NOT RECEIVED A COPY
OF THAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU DO
I WITHIN THAT WE HAVE A BROKEN
OUT SOME OF THE TYPES OF
INCENTIVES THAT WE'VE HEARD
FEEDBACK ON FOR PEOPLE AND THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD EXPLORE.
ADS MAKE OFFERED IN THIS
PROPOSAL. I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT VRY GOOD. TO
CONTINUE STAY DURING.
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER. TO
FURTHER FINE TUNE OUT THE
INITIATIVES THAT WERE RELEASED
IN THE APRIL SIXTEENTH VERSION.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FEEDBACK FROM PEOPLE ON THE
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT ON
INCENTIVE PROPOSALS. WE AIM TO
COMPLETE THE DESIGN OF THE
INCENTIVES BY OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR. TO ALLOW LOCAL ENTITIES
TO BEGIN THE INCENTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH ONE ANOTHER
PRIOR TO THE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TO GO LIVE DATE. WE WOULD ALSO
JUST NOTE IN REGARDS TO- THE
YOU KNOW THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITY. I'M SO WE ARE
PROPOSING TO IMPLEMENT THE-
INTERVENTION INCENTIVES WITHIN
THE FRAME WORK OF BEAT UP
INCENTIVE BANDS IN OUR MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS ESSENTIALLY
IT'S 5% ABOVE THE- MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS TO OUR MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS. OF THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS- MAYBE ONLY
MADE TO THE PLANTS IF THEY MEET
SPECIFIC TARGET SO IT'S NOT A
GRANT PROGRAM. BUT THEY DO HAVE
TO MEET THE TARGETS IN ORDER TO
DRIVE DOWN THE INCENTIVES WHICH
COULD INCLUDE THE REQUIRED-
INVOLVEMENT OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY PARTNERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE INCENTIVES.
ARE DRYING AND ALL THE RIGHT
PLAYERS IN THAT THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO JUST ACHIEVE THOSE
INCENTIVES WITHOUT. ACHIEVING
THE OBJECTIVES OF THE INCENTIVE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE PUT
FORWARD. ON THERE WILL BE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY
HAVE TO MEET YOU- RECEIVE THOSE
INCENTIVES AS WELL AS
DISCUSSIONS AROUND HOW THE
DOLLARS FLOW DOWNSTREAM. TO
SCHOOLS. AS WELL AS THE MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS. I AT AWE CAN
PROVIDE INFORMATION IF IT'S IF
IT'S WANTED YOU REGARDS TO THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS IN WHICH WE
USED TO DRIVE DOWN THE SPINES
THE DEPARTMENT HAS USED THIS
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR PREVIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTEGRATION
PILOTS THAT ARE ACTIVE RIGHT
NOW- AND IT IS THE SAME FEDERAL
AUTHORITY THAT WE ARE USING FOR
THE CATALAN INCENTIVE PROPOSALS
AS WELL. ESSENTIALLYIT IS A
WAY FOR US TO INCENTIVIZE
DELIVERY SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION-
MAKE IT ACHIEVABLE AND HAVE
YIELD OUTCOMES WHERE THEY DO
HAVE TO MEET THE OBJECTIVES IN
ORDER TO DRAW THEM DOWN THEY
MUST BE TIME LIMITED THEY
CANNOT BE AUTOMATICALLY
RENEWED- AND THE DEPARTMENT
MUST MAKE SURE IT ALIGNS WITH
OUR QUALITY STRATEGY TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS. SO THIS ENDS MY
COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY I
JUST WANTED TO ASK IF YOU DID
WANT THE DEPARTMENT TO GO INTO
ANY ADDITIONAL DETAIL REGARDING
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE AT
THIS TIME OR WHETHER THE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO WAIT FOR FUTURE
MAY REVISION I'M HEARING IS
HAPPY TO DO. WHATEVER YOUR YOUR
PREFERENCES. NO I THINK- I
THINK WE'LL HEAR SOME. ALL
RIGHT. SO I AS MENTIONED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
PROPOSAL REQUESTS FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS- AND I'LL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CHILDREN OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- INCENTIVES
OR INITIATIVES REALLY THIS IS A
AN AGENCY WIDE PROPOSAL
INCLUDING MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS-
IT INCLUDES BOTH THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- DMH SEE OF LIKE HELP
THE OFFICE OF SURGEON GENERAL
AND OFF AT WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS
COMPREHENSIVE PROPOSAL- SO I
WILL GIVE AN OVERVIEW REGARDING
PIECES. ON ALL PIECES OF THE
PROPOSAL TODAY HOWEVER WE JUST
NOTE IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
OUTSIDE OF WHAT YES YES WILL BE
SPURS SPECIFICALLY LEADING I
MAY HAVE TO DEFER THOSE TO
FUTURE HEARINGS THANK YOU THE
GOAL OF THE INITIATIVE IS
REALLY TO TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM INTO AN INNOVATIVE
UPSTREAM FOCUS ON MORE ALL
CHILDREN- UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE REGARDLESS OF PAYER
ARE ROUTINELY SCREENED
SUPPORTED AND SERVED FOR
MERGING AN EXISTING BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS. SERVICES WOULD BE
STATEWIDE EVIDENCE BASED
CULTURALLY. COMPETENT AND
EQUITY FOCUSED. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT DROVE THIS IS THE
TIMING IS SO CRITICAL WE HAVE
LEARNED SERVING YOUNG PEOPLE
AND DOING IT WELL PAYS OFF.
HALF OF ALL LIFE LIFETIME CASES
OF DIAGNOSABLE MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESS BEGINS AT AGE FOURTEEN
THREE FORCE OF LIKE TEN CASES
ARE DIAGNOSED. ARE BEGINNING BY
AGE TWENTY FIVE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT AS A VALUE WAITING OUR
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SYSTEMS IT IS CURRENTLY
INADEQUATE AND NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF MANY. IS TO FOCUS ON
PREVENTION. IT IS A SERVING TOO
FEW PROGRAMS TOO FEW BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS READ ME
THE NEEDED SERVICES. THERE ARE
TOO FEW CRISIS AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES. AND THERE ARE TOO FEW
ACUTE CARE SERVICES AND BEDS
THE PROPOSAL IS AIMING TO CLOSE
MANY OF THOSE HISTORICAL GAPS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME OF THE
MOST GLARING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES ARE BORN IN NEXT
WEEK BY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES AND PLACES WHERE
ADVERSE CHILD EXPERIENCES ARE
WIDESPREAD PROBLEM THAT. THE
JOURNAL OF AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REPORTED MENTAL
HEALTH IN RELATED VISITS FOR
CHILDREN AGES FIVE TO ELEVEN
WERE UP TWENTY FOUR PERCENT.
AND YOUTH TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE PERCENT. AS A FAMILY
FOUNDATION REPORTED THAT FIFTY
SIX POINT 2% OF AMERICANS
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FOUR REPORTED SYMPTOMS OF
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION. AND IN
THE SAME COHORT ROUGHLY 25%
DESCRIBED AN INCREASE OF ONSET
OF A SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND TWENTY
SIX REPORTED SERIOUS THOUGHTS
OF SUICIDE. THE PROPOSAL THAT
WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD IN THE
MAY REVISION IS A MULTI YEAR
INITIATIVE WITH ONE YOUR FOCUS
WITH THE FIRST YOU'RE FOCUSED
ON RESEARCH. PLANNING CAN BE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE WE
BUILD THIS RIGHT. I'LL GO OVER
THE MAIN COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL. A NEW STATEWIDE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM TO SCREEN AND
PROVIDE INITIAL FOLLOW UP CARE
AND TOOLS TO SUPPORT ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE THROUGH AGE TWENTY FIVE
AS MENTIONED EARLIER EARLIER
AND REGARDLESS OF PAYER I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART TO
REMEMBER THIS IS NOT JUST A
MEDICARE PROPOSAL IS FOR ALL
CHILDREN. IN CALIFORNIA. THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM WOULD PROVIDE
INTERACTIVE EDUCATION SELF
MONITORING TOOLS APPLICATION
BASED GAMES VIDEOS BOOKS
SUGGESTIONS AUTOMATED COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY AND
MINDFULNESS EXERCISES DESIGNED
TO BUILD SKILLS AND ENHANCE
WELL BEING AS WELL AS DIRECT
ACCESS. TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PEERS COACHES AND LICENSED
CLINICIANS THROUGH THAT PORTAL.
SERVICES WOULD BE PROVIDED VIA
A TIERED MODEL DELIVER AND
MONITOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT SO THAT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE MEANS RESOURCE
INTENSIVE TREATMENT IS BEING
DELIVERED FIRST AND REFERRALS
TO PLANS FOR HIGHER LEVELS OF
SERVICES WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
THE SYSTEM WOULD BE A UNIVERSAL
POINT OF ENTRY TO ASSIST
CHILDREN AND YOUTH TO CONNECT
TO SERVICES. THE PLATFORM WOULD
BE- BUT ALSO INCLUDE REFERRALS
TO INDIVIDUALS COMMERCIAL
HEALTH INSURANCE MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS JOHNNY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
SCHOOLING TO COUNSELORS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER RESOURCES FOR HIGHER
LEVEL BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES
WHEN THOSE ARE NEEDED. ALL
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE AND
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO PAY FOR
SCHOOL COUNSELOR SERVICES.
EMPLOYED BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
IN SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES AND COUNTIES BASED
ON A STATEWIDE NETWORK AND FEE
SCHEDULE. THE SYSTEM WOULD ALSO
CONNECT CHILDREN YOUTH AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS TO A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN OFFER
ADDITIONAL BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SUPPORTS AND WELLNESS SERVICES
IN THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY. THE
SYSTEM WOULD PROVIDE YOU
CONSOLE IN THE REFERRAL
SERVICES TO ALLOW PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRIC AND FAMILY PRACTICE
PRACTITIONERS TO RECEDE
ASYNCHRONOUS SUPPORT AND
CONSULTATION TO MANAGE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
FOR PATIENTS AND THEIR
PRACTICES. HOWEVER TO ACHIEVE
THIS TYPE OF TRANSFORMATION WE
HAVEN'T PUT FORWARD A NUMBER OF
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO BUILD
UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE STATEWIDE.
THIS WOULD INCLUDE. THE
BUILDING UP OF THE CONTINUUM OF
PROGRAMS AND WORKFORCE TO
SUPPORT THE CARE FOR THE SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS. IT WOULD
IMPLEMENT THE SUPPORT AND SCALE
UP AND SPREAD OF EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS PROVEN TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. WITH OR AT HIGH RISK OF
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS BUT
THE PARTICULAR FOCUS ON YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE THEIR FIRST
BREAK OR FIRST EPISODE OF
PSYCHOSIS. AND FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES SIX
STATEWIDE. THESE WOULD BE
GRANTS THAT WE WOULD
PARTICIPATE IN AFTER ENGAGING
WITH OUR MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTAKE THAT I
MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING OF
MY TALKING POINTS. ADDITIONALLY
WE WOULD INCREASE CAPACITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR SCHOOLING SERVICES. BY
ADDING GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
COUNTIES TRIBAL ENTITIES
SCHOOL. SCHOOLS COMMERCIAL AND
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. THESE FUNDS ARE IN
ADDITION TO THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN SCHOOLS DOLLARS WHICH
WE JUST PRESENTED ON WITHIN
THIS COMMITTEE. AND PUT FORWARD
IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET. HOWEVER THESE FUNDS BUT
FLOW DIRECTLY TO THE ENTITIES
THAT I JUST REFERENCED INSTEAD
NOT FOR THE MANAGED CARE PLANS.
AS A DIRECTOR LIKE BORN
MENTIONED CRITICAL TO BUILD OFF
OF THE PROPOSAL THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY AS WELL. WE ALSO WOULD BE
EXPANDING THE OVERALL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BY INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF BOTH SCHOOL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNSELORS.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH COACHES THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE STATEWIDE AS
WELL AS THE OVERALL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE NEEDS. THERE
WOULD BE A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
CREATE A PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN TO REDUCE THE STIGMA
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
ENCOURAGE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES. TO SEEK THE
NEEDED CARE BEFORE A CRISIS AND
TO BUILD A COMMON UNDERSTANDING
OF ACES AND TOXIC STRESS. WE
WILL ALSO BUILD ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND AS YOU D. BEDS
FACILITIES AND SERVICES. AND TO
PROVIDE MORE IN PERSON SERVICES
WHEN NEEDED ADDING DOLLARS TO
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUING INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY THE
GOVERNOR IN JANUARY. THE FOCUS
ON OFFERING SOCIAL MODELS AND
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS PROVIDING
CRISIS STABILIZATION CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES IN A HOME
LIKE SETTING AS WELL AS
BUILDING OUT OUR YOUTH. AND
CHILD OUTPATIENT AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WELLNESS HUBS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO
WORK TO IMPLEMENT THE DYADIC
SERVICES IN MEDICARE. WHERE THE
CARE IS DELIVERED IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE CARE GIVER AND
FAMILY SO THAT FAMILIES ARE
SCREENED FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROBLEMS IN OUR PERSONAL SAFETY
SUBSTANCE USE AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. UP
FRONT. WE ALSO WOULD BE WORKING
TO IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE
EDUCATION AWARENESS CAMPAIGN TO
RAISE THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
LITERACY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
NORMALIZE AND SUPPORT THE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. AT THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE USE
CHALLENGES TEACH CALIFORNIANS
HOW TO RECOGNIZE EARLY SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF DISTRESS AND
WHERE TO TURN AND ASK FOR HELP.
EMPOWERING CHILDREN AND USED TO
TAKE CHARGE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. DEVELOP A
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN ON
ACES AND TOXIC STRESS WHICH
WILL INCLUDE THELATEST
EVIDENCE OF TRAUMA INFORMED IN
TRAUMA SENSITIVE RESPONSES.
INITIATIVE WIDE WE WOULD HAVE
AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR OF ALL
PROGRAM COMPONENTS TO IDENTIFY
THE BEST INNOVATIVE PRACTICES
AND INFORM FUTURE POLICY WORK
THROUGHOUT THESE MULTI YEAR
INITIATIVES. THE BAT IS THE
ACTUAL COLLUSION OF THE
OVERVIEW OF THE CHILDREN'S AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE FORWARD AND THE
GOVERNORS MAY REVISION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS THIS CONTINUES
THROUGH COMMITTEES AND HEARINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DEBBIE
DIRECTOR DEAD UBER- AND I AND I
SHOULD SAY THAT I DID HAVE A
BRIEF CONVERSATION WITH DR
KELLY YESTERDAY BEFORE THIS WAS
ANNOUNCED AND- APPROPRIATE YOUR
DESCRIPTION OF THE OF THE
PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
AND I AND I WOULD SAY THAT WE
ALL AGREE. ON THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM AS YOU DESCRIBED IT-
AND- AND WE- AND I AND I GUESS
I SHOULD JUST SAY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LOOKS FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND ACTUALLY
FLESHING OUT THIS PROPOSAL- SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE. THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF STUFF SUCCESS AM. AND
I YOU KNOW IT IS THIS IS THIS
IS NOT YOUR RESPONSIBILITY BUT
I DO I WOULD JUST THINK IT
BEARS. SAYING AS WE AS WE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE RIGHT NOW.
WITH THE ISSUES AT THE- AT THE
EDT WHAT I THINK- THIS LAST
WEEK THERE WAS A 6% RESPONSE TO
THE CALLS AND EMAILS I CAME IN-
ONLINE AND SO IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SENDING UP A WHOLE BRAND
NEW. ONLINE SYSTEM OR THE MOST
VULNERABLE VULNERABLE ARE GONNA
BE CONTACTING IT. BEING ASSURED
THAT HELP IS GOING TO BE THERE.
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO PARTNER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS DONE.
PUBLISHED SUCCESS AND WE DON'T
JUST RAISE UP HOPES IF WE CAN
ACTUALLY EXECUTE SO. I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
ON THE MANAGED CARE PART OF IT
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN DOING. AND
I GUESS THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING. ON THIS NEW
PROPOSAL GOING FORWARD. JUST
WANT TO SPEAK ON THE
SPECIFICALLY BEFORE WE MOVED TO
OUR PANEL DR PAM. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE THE
A PRESENTATION BY OUR MEDICAID
DIRECTOR- J. C. COOPER- AND
REALLY APPRECIATE IT-
GOVERNORS- ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER. I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT-
SAYS- HER MEDICAID DIRECTOR-
RAN THROUGH SOME OF THE
STATISTICS ABOUT THE NEEDS AND
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
INTREPID PROPOSAL THE SCOPE
THAT'S GONNA. TAKE SOME TIME
AND STUDY TO DO IT RIGHT- THAT
THE NEED IS IMMEDIATE AND SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
THIS- CHALLENGE OF- OF- THE
FACT THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE AND EVEN AS WE ARE
PLANNING FIGURING THIS OUT-
THEY MAY BE DETERIORATING AND-
IN TERMS OF THE- THE- UNCERTAIN
TERMS OR STATUS AND SO- I THINK
WE GOT THINK CAREFULLY ABOUT
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS WHAT KIND OF SUPPORT
WE CAN PROVIDE TO PEOPLE. IS
EVEN AS WE ARE TRYING TO BUILD
THIS OUT BUT- I DO APPRECIATE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT TRYING TO
FELT THEY STAYED NINE. A
STATEWIDE NETWORK- IT'S PRETTY
CHEAP TO STRINGS THAT WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW VARIOUS
COUNTIES AND SO FORTH BUT- WE
DO NEED I THINK A STATEWIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE- I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT SCHOOLING
SERVICES ARE GOING TO BE
AGNOSTIC IN TERMS OF. YOUR
SOURCE OF COVERAGE. BECAUSE
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A CHALLENGE
RIGHT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
TO SERVE ALL OF ITS STUDENTS
EQUALLY. BUT YET YOU HAVE
STUDENTS WHO ARE ON MEDICARE
WELL YOU HAVE STUDENTS WHO ARE
UNINSURED YOU HAVE STUDENTS ON
A COMMERCIAL INSURANCE. TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE BE SURE
THOSE PARTICULAR- YEAH-
DIFFERENCES DON'T END UP
CAUSING DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
ACCESS IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND AT
THE SAME TIME SETTING UP THE
KIND OF RULES THAT ALLOW THESE
PROGRAMS TO BE SUSTAINABLE HI
SO I APPRECIATE THE- THIS
INITIAL INVESTMENT BUT- IN THE
END- THOSE ARE. THOSE ARE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND BEING
SURE THAT THE US. THAT THE
SERVICES CAN BE. EVENTUALLY GOT
REIMBURSED. AS WELL- WHAT IS
ONE QUESTION I DO HAVE AND I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
PANEL- BUT CERTAINLY AS CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. WON THE BIG
BARRIERS TO ANY SORT OF GOT.
SERVICES WE HAVE AS LONG. ACT
AND CONVEY THAT THERE. WHO CAN
SPEAK LANGUAGE HOW MUCH. WORK
THEY CAN DO SO CAN YOU PERHAPS
SPEAK- THE DIRECT COOPER- TO
THE- COMMITMENT TO LANGUAGE
ACCESS. WE HAVE CERTAINLY MANY
STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS WHO ARE
NOT PRIMARY ENGLISH LEARNERS
ARE PRIMARY ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
AND THEN WE TALKED ABOUT YOU
TODAY ATTIC COMPONENT. FOR YOUR
INVOLVING FAMILIES AS WELL AND-
EVEN MORE OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS
PERHAPS AREN'T PRIMARY ENGLISH
SPEAKER SO. HE SPEAK TO THE-
THE COMMITMENT TO LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND IN THIS PROPOSAL.
YES I CAN I CAN DEFINITELY SAY
THAT WOULD BE A CORE FOCUS OF
MAKING SURE THAT IT IS- AS
SENSITIVE TO THOSE ITEMS THAT
WE ARE LINGUISTICALLY A
PROVIDING SERVICES WITHIN
SOMEONE'S LANGUAGE WHEN
POSSIBLE- AND WE WOULD
DEFINITELY TAKE THAT TO THE
GROUP TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING THAT TYPE OF ACCESS
AND SERVICES. OKAY SO I THINK
THAT AGAIN- I REALIZE THERE'S
CHALLENGES THERE OFTENTIMES THE
PROVIDER THEMSELVES THE MIDDLE
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDER MAY NOT NECESSARILY
BE- YOU KNOW SPEAKING- MISSED
THE ALL THE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
THAT WE NEED IN THE COVER BUT-
WE COULD DEFINITELY TRYING TO
BE SURE- I THINK. YOU KNOW. I
HEAR A LOT OF IF POSSIBLE AND
SO FORTH AND I REALIZED THERE-
BUT- IT WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
SOME VERY STRONG COMMITMENT TO-
TO LANGUAGE ACCESS- OTHERWISE
WE'LL LEAVE OUT. UNFORTUNATELY
LARGE CHUNKS OF SIGHT
CALIFORNIANS- AND- SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID BUT-
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE-
PROPOSALS AND PARTICULARLY IN
RELATION TO HAVING A SURE
LANGUAGE ACCESS. TO ALL THE
STUDENTS TO THE STUDENTS WHO
NEED THE SERVICES AND THAT BY
THE WAY THAT ALSO BY WAY OF THE
LAST OF THE STIGMA ISSUES WELL.
SO- APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT PAN. OF
MR EWING DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK
AT ALL ABOUT BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE PANEL I'M SORRY THAT I.
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AT
ALL. MY COMMENTS ARE LARGELY
FOCUSED ON THE- PROPOSAL TO
SUBMIT TO EXPAND UPON THE-
STUDENT SERVICES ACT BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THAT- MANY
OF THE PRIORITIES ARE AREAS OF
FOCUS THAT DIRECTOR COOPER LAID
OUT IN THE- VERY BROAD PROPOSAL
WHICH CLEARLY. KNOW NEEDS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF PLANNING
ARE VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE
TRENDS THAT WE'RE SEEING
INTERNATIONALLY. RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO BE MUCH MORE
RESPONSIVE TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE LIVES OF INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES RATHER THAN
ASKING THOSE FAMILIES TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO HOW WE DESIGNED
THE SYSTEM. AND THAT INCLUDES
STARTING WITH THE PREMISE THAT
WE NEED TO DELIVER CARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED CARE AND
SUPPORT AND WE SHOULD REALLY
DESIGNED OUR SYSTEM. AND THEN
HAVE FINDING SUPPORT THAT
SYSTEM RATHER THAN HAVE OUR
SYSTEM REFLECT FUNDING ON IT.
SO I'M I'M HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT BROADER PROPOSAL AROUND
THE MEDICAL STUDENT SERVICES
ACT AND WHAT WE HOPE IS A
STRONG COORDINATION AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROPOSAL TO ENGAGE
MANAGED CARE PLANS- BUT I WAS
PLANNING TO DO THAT. ON OUR YOU
KNOW MORE SPECIFICALLY IN
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION THEN
THE ANALYSIS ON THE NHS AND
SAY. ISSUE OKAY. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN WE CERTAINLY DO NOT
DISAGREE WITH ANY OF THE NEEDS
THAT HAVE BEEN STATED NOPE
NOBODY NOBODY DISAGREES WITH
THAT- I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HAS
MADE IT THROUGH. THIS PANDEMIC
WITHOUT WITHOUT FEELING THE
EFFECTS OF IT ON THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH. AND I KNOW I HAVE A
TWELVE YEAR AT HOME I KNOW
DOCTOR PAN HAS YOUNG PEOPLE AT
HOME I KNOW. I A A SINNER
TROUBLE HAS HAS CHILDREN AS
WELL SO WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT THAT THIS PANDEMIC IS
OUT. BUT THE LONG TERM UNDER
INVESTMENT WE'VE HAD IN MENTAL
HEALTH AND THAT THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE PANEL
NOW- IF NOBODY ELSE AND HE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS AND I KNOW ONE OF
OUR PANELISTS. HAS TO LEAVE
EARLY- WHEN WE'VE GONE ON A
LITTLE LONG HERE SO I BELIEVE
IT IS DR ERICA. SIMON ISSUE THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT FROM A
STUDENT SERVICES IN LONG BEACH
UNIFIED IS GOING TO SPEAK AND
DOES HELP ME INTRODUCE
EVERYBODY ELSE'S GONNA SPEAKING
NO WE'RE GONNA START. WITH
DOCTOR SIMON. WE HAVE A SEAN
FRANCIS ALSO ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
HEALTH COLLABORATIONS FOR
CHILDREN NOW WE HAVE. LEAH-
GORDO FROM DIRECTOR OF THE
SERVICE THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
AND LINNEA COOKMAN ACTING CEO
OF THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THEY'VE BEEN
GIVING A SERIES OF QUESTIONS TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE DEPARTMENTS. OF PROPOSALS.
AND LET'S START WITH DR SIMON.
SO GOOD EVENING OR GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON SKEWS ME. STERN AND
MADAM CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE-MEMBERS IT IS A PRIVILEGE AND
HONOR TO BE WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS JOINT
HEARING MY NAME IS ERIN SIMON
AND I SERVED AS THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOL
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR THE FOURTH
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE BEACH UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I ALSO HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING AS THE
STATE'S VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS.
ADMINISTRATORS HELLO MICHELLE
BY SCHOOL DISTRICT BELIEVES AN
EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO LINKING
STUDENTS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES WHERE STUDENTS ARE. AT
SCHOOL. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COUNTY AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS I CAN SAY
THAT WE PLAYED A LEADING ROLE
TO PLAY. AND THE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. IT HAS BEEN
STATED THAT OVER 70% OF
STUDENTS RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OUR SCHOOLS. WHICH
CLEARLY SHOWS THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IS THE GREAT EQUALIZER
AS A CHEMICAL PROVIDES SUPPORT
FOR ALL STUDENTS NO MATTER
THEIR ZIP COLD. OR SOCIAL
STATUS. COOL SITES ARE PRIME
LOCATIONS TO CONDUCT SCREENINGS
AND ASSESSMENTS PROVIDE
TREATMENT LINKED TO SERVICES IN
THE COMMUNITY COORDINATE CASE
MANAGEMENT FOR STUDENTS PROVIDE
TEACHER TRAINING TO CREATE A
POSITIVE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL. AND PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
SERVICES AND I THINK YOU HEARD
THAT WAS SOME OF THE REMARKS
THAT WERE MADE EARLIER. TOP
AMONG THE CHALLENGES. IS THE
LACK OF RESOURCES THE LACK OF
NON MEDICAL AGENCIES- EVEN THE
LACK OF CASE MANAGEMENT
OFFERINGS FOR AGENCIES THAT DO
HAVE MEDICARE OUT. THE COMPOUND
COMPETING AGENCIES BETWEEN
COUNTY AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED PROVIDERS AND WHICH ALSO
PRESENTS A SET OF INEQUITIES
FOR NON MEDICARE FAMILY. THAT'S
IT ALTHOUGH ONE TIME FUNDING
HAS BEEN USEFUL FOR DISTRICTS
WE TRULY APPRECIATE IT THERE IS
A NEED FOR LONG TERM FUNDING TO
TACKLE LONG LASTING MENTAL
HEALTH THE- SERVICES THAT ARE
OFFERED REGARDLESS OF. PAYER SO
ALL CHILDREN CAN RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE. THERE'S. ALSO A
NEED FOR SYSTEMIC MINUTES WERE
MAY HEALTH. FOR TEACHERS SCHOOL
SITES THAT AND I'M AND I'M- BUT
YOU KNOW. CARD IN IT SINCE LAST
INTENSIVE STAN. BETTER BASED.
AND CULTURALLY SENSITIVE INCOME.
MISS HEALTH AND SCHOOL HE ALSO.
COMMUNITY SEE SCHOOLS AS A
SENSE OF SUPPORT THEY FEEL MORE
COMPETENT TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL THE
SHUTTERING OF SCHOOL SYSTEMS
AMID COLD IT SEPARATE STUDENTS
FROM MUCH MORE THAN JUST
CLASSROOMS FRIENDS AND HOBBIES
IT ALSO CUT ALL STUDENTS FROM
CARING STAFF SERVICE MENTORS.
LIFESAVERS AND HELP STUDENTS
BUILD SELF ESTEEM AND COPE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND TRAUMA. CALL
IT WE HAVE A LONG LASTING
EFFECTS. PARENTS AND GUARDIANS.
WE'VE ALWAYS PRIORITIZES THE
STATE AS A NATION THE CORE
ACADEMIC NEEDS OF STUDENTS
RIGHT FOR CENTURIES. IT'S ALL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING MUST BE PRIORITIZED AS
WELL. STUDENTS MUST MASTER
BEFORE THEY BLOW GREAT
OPPORTUNITY COMES WITH GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY. I AM PREPARED
AND HAPPY TO GO INTO DETAIL
ABOUT. THE DISTRICT OF MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT OUR
REFERRAL PROC PROCESS OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR COMMITTEE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
OR ANY OTHER TOPIC THE
COMMITTEE WISHES TO DISCUSS
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
DON'T THINK I SAID ANYTHING
THAT NO ONE ELSE HAS SAID. I'M
ON THIS PANEL- BUT I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE FROM A SCHOOL
DISTRICT PROSPECTUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY- IT'S
BECAUSE BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS IN SPECIFIC AND I
GUESS I WOULD JUST ASK DID YOU
SAY IT IS YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
PART OF A- I MEAN JUST AS A
PARTNERSHIP. WE ARE NOT WE ARE
PART OF A SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS WHERE WE
HAVE SEVERAL SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS OR UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
THEY HELP US WITH COLLECTED
HERE THREE INTENSIVE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR AT THIS POINT OKAY BUT LET
US AND MOVE ON- WITH THE REST
OF THE PANEL LET ME SEE. ATRIA
TO GET GLASSES ON AND OFF TO BE
ABLE TO SEE. WHAT SHOULD WE GO
BACK UP AND- TO START FROM THE
TOP ANGLE WITH A LINEAR KRUGMAN
COOKED COOKED COOKED MAN'S- PUT
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA. RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BY NAME FOR THE ACTIVE
AND I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH AND THE CALIFORNIA. SHE
FEELS THE STATEWIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
SIXTEEN NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED MEDIC HOW MANAGED CARE
PLANS. THAT SERVE OVER EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED
IN MEDI CAL. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE OBJECTIVES OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND WE DID A PROGRAM
AS A VALUABLE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND ACCESS AND INCREASE OUR
PARTNERS THAT SHIP. WITH GOLD
AND COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS.
I'LL BRIEFLY RESPOND TO THE
FOUR QUESTIONS HE ASKED AND
THEN HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
OTHERS AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
FIRST WITH RESPECT TO
INCREASING ACCESS TO THE ORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. LOCAL PLANTS
BELIEVE OUR ROLE IS BOTH ABOUT
PROMOTING AWARENESS AND
PROVIDING ACCESS TO CARE. LOCAL
PLANS IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES TO
ENSURE THAT YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE AWARE OF AVAILABLE
SERVICES AND HOW TO ACCESS
THEM. INCLUDING PUBLISHING
MENTAL HEALTH FOCUSED MEMBER
NEWSLETTERS. SOCIAL MEDIA
CAMPAIGN PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT. I THANK THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUPS. AND
DISTURBING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFORMATION THE SCHOOL
DIRECTLY. NEED EFFORT HAS LED
TO AN INCREASE IN PENETRATION
OF THE MILD TO MODERATE BENEFIT
IN RECENT YEARS FOR BOTH ADULTS
AND CHILDREN. SECOND HELLO
PLANNED COORDINATE WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN SCHOOLS
TODAY. THIS DOES LOOK DIFFERENT
DEPENDING ON THE PLAN AND THEIR
COUNTY ISN'T COOL. THAT MANY
PLANTS AND INDICATED THAT THEY
HAVE REGULAR MEETINGS WITH
THEIR COUNTY. HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. WHICH IN SOME CASES
AND CRITICAL. IN ADDITION SOME
PLANS HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS.
ARE CONTRACTED PROVIDERS IN
THEIR NETWORK THAT BILL FOR
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. OR WHEN THE COUNTY
HAS A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE SCHOOL FOR NATUREFOR ALL
TO THE PLANT CONTRACTED.
PROVIDERS FOR MILD TO MODERATE
SERVICES. THIRD ARE RECOMMENDED
CHANGES OR IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
OVERALL WE APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
NECESSARY GIVEN THE DIVERSITY
OF NEED I THINK THE THING
RELATIONSHIPS ACROSS THE STATE.
WE DO BELIEVE THE PROGRAM WILL
BE A SIGNIFICANT LEFT FOR ALL
PARTNERS AND WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE FIRST YEAR OF THE PROGRAM
LARGELY FOCUSED ON. HE AIN'T
TRAINING THE COURT FOR SCHOOL
COUNTY AND PLANNED. TO CONDUCT
NEEDS ASSESSMENTS OR GAP
ANALYSES AND THAT ALL THE
PROJECT PLAN WITH SPECIFIC
MILESTONES. HOWEVER WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME PROJECTS
MAY BE READY TO GO SEE HER.
AGAIN AND POSSIBILITY WILL BE
KEY. THEY ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
THERE BE CLEAR DIRECTION ON
EXPECTATIONS FOR RECORDING
MILESTONES AND METRICS.
ADDITIONALLY GIVEN THAT THERE
ARE OVER ONE THOUSAND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE. FURTHER DISCUSSION IS
NEEDED REGARDING WHAT LEVEL OF
COORDINATION- LOCALLY
PARTICULARLY FOR PLANNING.
PROCESS FEES AND LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE. AND LASTLY L. TO
BARRIERS TO CONTACTING THE
SCHOOL. WE DO BELIEVE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES IS A
VERY DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
BETWEEN OUR SYSTEM'S. PLANET
ENTERING INTO DIRECT CONTACT
WITH THE SCHOOL. SCHOOL WOULD
BECOME A NETWORK PROVIDER OF
THE PLAN WHICH COMES TO
SPECIFIC FEDERAL AND STATE%
REQUIREMENTS. SUCH AS
ENROLLMENT AND CREDENTIALING
ENCOUNTER DATA SUBMISSION
CLAIMS AND BILLING AND DATA
SHARING. THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
UNDERTAKING WHICH IS WHY THEY
WILL NEED. TO BE SUBSTANTIAL PA
AND TRAINING. WHERE THIS
PROCESS WE ALSO CONTRACT
TEMPLATE MODELS WOULD BE
HELPFUL RESOURCE. HOWEVER I'LL
MENTION THAT WE DON'T SEE
DIRECT CONTRACTING IS THE ONLY
OPTION OR BEST OPTION FOR EVERY
SCHOOL. OTHER MODELS SUCH AS
EMBEDDING NAVIGATORS OR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS WITH
AN ACTUAL ARE HAVING SCREENINGS
AND REFERRALS AT SCHOOL SITES.
ARE OTHER APPROACHES THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED. AND WHICH
MEET THE GOAL OF IMPROVING
ACCESS TO HEALTH FOR STUDENTS.
SO IN SOME WAYS THE PART OF THE
AIMS OF THE PROPOSAL AND WE
REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE IMPORTANT
DETAILS. YES THE LEGISLATURE
AND. OUR COUNTY IN FULL
PARTNERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY ABOUT THE-
TED MS CLARK. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY I SPOKE
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
BECAUSE OVER HALF OF ALL
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL
CAN YOU BE HERE FOR A HEALTH
AGENCIES HAVE PARTNERED OVER
DECADES WITH SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO
ENSURE THE PROVISION OF HEALTH
SERVICES ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES IN
FACT 85% OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
PROVIDING MEDIC MEDIC HOW
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES RIGHT NOW. WITH
TWENTY COUNTIES COVERING
BETWEEN EIGHTY AND 1100% OF
SCHOOL CAMPUSES WITHIN THEIR
COUNTIES WE ALSO HAVE TO KEEP
5% OF COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
PROVIDING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES THE MOST COMMON MODEL
TO KEEP THE COUNTY HEALTH USES
FOR SCHOOL BASED SERVICES IT'S
A PARTNERSHIP WITH SCHOOLS
USING A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING SCHOOL STAFF
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR ARMS AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES OPERATE ON SCHOOL
SITES AND PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES UNDER THE E. P.
S. D. T. PENDANT BENEFIT.
SCHOOL STAFF REFER STUDENTS
RECEIVING ARMS AS WELL AS
STUDENTS THAT ARE MEETING
ACADEMIC STANDARDS MAY NOT
QUALIFY FOR- ARMS ONSITE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN ANOTHER COMMON
MODEL. SCHOOLS CONTRACT WITH K.
EVER AGENTS. TO PROVIDE ARMS
SERVICE ON SITES THANK WE HAVE
A HEALTHY. ALL PROVIDE P. PST
T. SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS ON THE
SCHOOL SITE. ALTHOUGH IT'S A
LESS COMMON MODEL COUNTY HERO
HEALTH AGENCIES DO CONTRACT
WITH SCHOOLS THAT SCHOOL STAFF.
TO PROVIDE MEDICARE
REIMBURSABLE SERVICES. INC AND
THIS MODEL TYPICALLY WE
CONTRACT WITH LICENSED SCHOOL
STAFF AS MEDI CAL PROVIDERS OR
WITH APPROPRIATELY TRAINED
SCHOOL BASED STAFF. THAT
PROVIDE ARMS OR AND OR PPS
CREDENTIALED STAFF TO PROVIDE A
LIMITED SET OF SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES APPROPRIATE FOR
DELIVERY ON THE SCHOOL SITE-
WHEN I MENTIONED SOME OF THE
BARRIERS SCOPE OF PRACTICE IS
ANOTHER ISSUE IN PARTICULAR
WITH. PPS CREDENTIALED STAFF
BECAUSE MANY OF THOSE STAFF
MEMBERS ARE NOT LICENSED AND
BECAUSE MEDIC HOW HAVE
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENTS. FOR
NON LICENSE STATUS. COUNTIES
BRADY FUNDING TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES MOST UTILIZE MEDIC HAL
AS FOR SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
THAT PAY THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
WITH BOTH AMATEUR STATE FUNDS
AND REALIGNMENT FUNDING AND IT
JUST SAY FUNDS ARE ALSO USED
FOR NON MEDICARE REIMBURSABLE
SERVICES. TO A SMALLER EXTENT
SCHOOLS DO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
SERVICES THE COUNTIES PROVIDE
WITH A FOCUS ON NON MEDICAL
REIMBURSABLE SERVICES USING EL
CAP AND OTHER SCHOOL FUNDS. A
FEW COUNT COUNTIES DO
SUCCESSFULLY BILL PRIVATE
INSURANCE FOR SOME
REIMBURSEMENT. AS INDICATED IN
THE ANALYSIS TO BE HT I
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT OF
INCREASING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN SCHOOLSIN A MANNER
THAT RECOGNIZES THE EXPENSIVE
SCHOOL BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND AGENCIES AGENCY
CONTRACTED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS WE'VE RECOMMENDED
ADDING MORE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES AS PART
OF THE INCENTIVES AND
INCENTIVES TIED. TO SERVING ALL
pALLOWING FOR THAT. AS WELL AS
ALLOWING FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
WELLNESS CENTERS AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ULTIMATELY WE
BELIEVE A THREE WAY PARTNERSHIP
BENEFITS SIGNIFICANTLY FROM
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PARTICIPATION AND LEADERSHIP
BECAUSE OF OUR UNIQUE ABILITY
UNDER STATE LAW TO SERVE AND BE
REIMBURSED. FOR CARE TO ALL
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES IN NEED
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN ADDITION AND MOST OF THE
SCHOOLS PARTNERSHIP
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATE IN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICE. ALSO
NON MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES AND
MANY SCHOOLS THAT WE SERVE AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SERVE ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THE
CUTIE IF THE DIAGNOSIS AND
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
ENTITY. IS FUNDS REMAIN AFTER
CAL AIM PAYMENT REFORM HAS BEEN
FULLY IMPLEMENTED IN ABOUTA
YEAR A LITTLE OVER A YEAR WE'RE
INTERESTED IN EXPLORING
BECOMING DIRECT RECIPIENTS OF
THESE FUNDS ASSUMING THAT
COUNTIES WILL BE ABLE TO PULL
DOWN FEDERAL MATCH PORT. FOREST
SIMILAR TYPE OF IT'S A SCHOOL
BASED. INCENTIVE PROGRAM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY- LET'S ON
AND- TO- MISSILE WILL SHARE
FRANCIS PLEASE PLAYER FRANCIS
I'M SORRY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LUSHAN FRANCIS AND I'M AN
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR AT CHILDREN
NOW THANK YOU SHARE AD MANAGER
LAYERED AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANT ISSUE
OF STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH. THE
BIG THING I'D LIKE TO DRIVE
HOME FOR YOU ALL TODAY IS THE
SAME ISSUE DR PAN RACE BRIEFLY
AND THAT IS THE ISSUE OF TIMING.
IMAGINE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING ONE OF ITS MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES. AND
INSTEAD OF DEPLOYING FIRST
RESPONDERS THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCES A PLAN FOR HOW TO USE
FIRST RESPONDERS FOR NEXT
YEAR'S FIRES. BOB GOOD STATE
GOVERNANCE INCLUDES PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE WE WOULD ALL
AGREE IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO LET
THE CURRENT FIRES BLAZE. THIS
IS BEEN THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH. ISN'T
URGENT NEED TO RESPOND TO THE
CURRENT CRISIS BUT THE STATE IS
FIGURING OUT HOW TO SUPPORT THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF STUDENTS IN A
YEAR OR TWO. DURING TWENTY
TWENTY THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF THESE ARTICLES OUTLINING THE
INCREASE IN EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS. RISING OVERDOSE DEATHS
AND HIGHLY PUBLICIZED SUICIDES
OF STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
URGENCY OF NEED IS EXACTLY WHY
OUR COALITION IN SUPPORTING THE
INCREASED INVESTMENT INTO THE
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
ACT IN THE AMOUNT OF EIGHTY
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IT
ALSO WOULD ALLOW STUDENTS
SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES WHO
ALREADY HAVE A PLAN AROUND
CRISIS INTERVENTION.
ASSESSMENTS MEETING FOR BUT A
HEALTH NEEDS TREATMENT AND
LINKAGES TO ADDITIONAL SERVICES
TO BE FUNDED. DEPENDING ON
COUNTY CAPACITY TO RESPOND B.
L. A. C. CAMP ROSTERS NEW
FUNDING AGREEMENTS AND
CONTRACTS WITH THE SCHOOLS
QUICKLY. AN INVESTMENT OF
EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION WILL
ALLOW COUNTIES LIKE MONTEREY
SACRAMENTO RIVERSIDE CINEMA AND
SAMPOERNA DINO TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OVER A MILLION
STUDENTS AND- IN MULTIPLE
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE COULD DO
VERY QUICKLY IS TO INVEST IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ON THE GROUND
SUPPORTING THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN WAYS THAT
MAY BE HARD FOR SCHOOLS TO DO.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
AMPLIFY WOULD DIRECTOR COOPER
JUST SAID AND YOUNG PRINCE OF
GIVING BACK ALORS DIRECTLY TO
CEOS. IN ADDITION TO EXPANDING
THE SCHOOL COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS
WE BELIEVE THAT THE INFLUX OF
DOLLARS THE STATE IS
EXPERIENCING SHOULD GO TO THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE USED LET
IT YOU. HOWARD AND SUPPORTING
FAMILY. HIS ORGANIZATIONS ARE
WORKING EVERY DAY TO NOT ONLY
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF ADVERSITIES
EXPERIENCED BY CHILDREN LIKE
COMMUNITY BACK VIOLENCE OR ALSO
PROVIDING IMMEDIATE SUPPORT TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHO DO
HAVE EXPERIENCES THAT SEVERELY
IMPACT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
TODAY AS YOU EXAMINE THE
PROPOSALS IN FRONT OF YOU
INCLUDING THE UPCOMING MAY
REVISION I LIKE MEMBERS TO
THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT WHA IS
BEING FUNDED THAT WOULD HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE TODAY AND WHAT IS
CHILDREN IN A FEW YEARS. TO BE
CLEAR CHILDREN NOW BELIEVES A
LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING AND WE'RE SUPPORTING
MANY OF THE PROPOSALS THE XPS
SCRIBE TODAY. HEY YOU'RE A
GNOSTIC INTER AGENCY
COLLABORATION IS SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR A WHILE.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE THE PROPOSAL
TOMORROW THAT DEREK- MENTION.
OUR ONLY CONCERN IS THAT WE ARE
IN A UNIQUE MOMENT OF TIME IN
NEED IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
THINKING ABOUT INVESTMENTS AND
TO SPEED UP MENTAL HEALTH AS-
IF IT IS AN- ACTUAL EMERGENCY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO BOTH. AS WE
EXAMINE MAY REVISE CLOSELY AND
OUR FINANCIAL SITUATION WE URGE
MEMBERS TO NOT ONLY THINK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN PLAN FOR. A MORE
ROBUST MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
SYSTEM IN THE FUTURE. BUT I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A CURRENT
FIRE IT HAS YET TO BE
EXTINGUISHED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'M HAPPY. TO
TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE MOMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU TO OUR
PANELISTS. I THINK. MY FIRST
QUESTION- IS I THINK YOU
MISSED. YOUR BUT MAYBE ANYBODY
ELSE TELL ME ABOUT YOUR WORK
FORCE ME WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO HIRE A LOT MORE
AND TO. PROVIDE A LOT MORE
RESOURCES. BUT WE KNOW WE ALSO
NEED TO REFER- TO. INVEST IN
OUR WORK FORCE THE ISSUE THE
DOCTOR CAN RAISE ISSUES AROUND.
THEM ED LANGUAGE ACCESS ACT ALL
OF THOSE THINGS TO TALK TO ME A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR WORK
FORCE AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
BUILD THAT UP CAN YOU HIRE
RIGHT NOW ARE YOU. HAVE A LOT
OF VACANCIES RIGHT NOW. I WOULD
SAY THAT WORKFORCE IS AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE AND THAT'S
WHY WE DID- DISCUSS WITH WITH
YOU IT'S YES AND THEY WERE VERY
RESPONSIVE. TO INCLUDING MORE
ON THE WORK FORCE HE'S IN THIS
PROPOSAL WORK FORCE TRAINING
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT. I DO WANT
TO MENTION THAT RIGHT NOW WE DO
HAVE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THE
STATE PROVIDED A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. TO INVEST IN OUR
WORK FORSTER STIPENDS LOAN
REPAYMENT AND- OTHER OTHER
MECHANISMS THAT ARE BEING RUN
THROUGH. THAT MONEY IS ABOUT TO
GO OUT SO WE ARE HOPING THAT
THAT SUPPORTS- SOME OF THIS
DEVELOPMENT. CURRENTLY WE USE.
A DIFFERENT MIXTURE OF BOTH
CURRENT CLINICAL STAFF AS WELL
AS WELL I'M WELL TRAINED.
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO PROVIDE
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO ACCESS CHILDREN WE ALSO USE
PEERS WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT. THE ABILITY TO
POTENTIALLY USE MORE PEERS AND-
ONCE ONCE. CERTIFICATION IS
LIFTED UP IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE ABLE TO BILL MEDICARE AL
FOR THE SERVICES THAT ARE GOING
TO BE PROVIDED BY PEERS. I'M
THE ONE AREA THAT I WOULD
MENTION IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
DISCUSSION IS. ON FEDERAL LAW
DOES REQUIRE THAT HERE'S TO BE
EIGHTEEN YEARS OR OLDER AND
HAVE. A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
EQUIVALENT SO YOU'VE PEERS
WHICH IS A VERY STRONG MODEL
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
SUPPORTED UNDER THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM BUT IT WILL BE
SOMETHING. THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO BE ACTIVE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE VALUE OF THAT
WORKFORCE SO- CENTER ADMIN I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU THAT THERE
IS LOTS OF NEEDS AROUND THEIR
OWN WORKFORCE RICK CITED TO
SEE. WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL WITH THE NEW FUNDING
BUT THEY'VE IDENTIFIED WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO MEAN FOR THE
PUBLIC. BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION THAT WE ARE DOING A GAP
ANALYSIS RIGHT NOW. WITH UCSF
HEALTH FOR CENTER THAT WE
AREN'T WHERE WE ARE IDENTIFYING
THE BIGGEST GAPS IN OUR WORK
FORCE. AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT
ONE OF THOSE BIG GAPS IS. IS
THE LANGUAGE SPOKEN BY MANY OF
OUR CONDITIONS- THAT IS THAT IS
A VERY HERE WE DO USE OBVIOUSLY
WITH. ALL THE MEDIC HELPER. WE
USE TRY. AND A TRIP. SERVICES
TO ENSURE THAT WE MEET WE MEET.
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS NEEDS OF
OUR POPULATION BUT- THE
PIPELINE. IS IT SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL NEED TO SERIOUSLY LOOK
AT IN TERMS OF THAT KIND OF
LANGUAGE FASTLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT THE HUGE MAYBE MR-
EWING CAN TALK ABOUT THAT LATER
I KNOW. EARLY ON WITH THE- WITH
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH MONEY WE I
DID WE DID A SPECIALTY CLASS
WITH THAT WITH API STUDENTS- TO
BE ABLE TO REALLY INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WITH LANGUAGE
DIVERSITY GOING OUT INTO THE
FIELD SO. I WOULD GUESS SOME
MORE PROGRAMS THAT REALLY FOCUS
ON SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES-
LANGUAGE ACCESS WILL NEED TO BE
FUNDED AS WE GO FORWARD IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
CLINICIANS THAT ARE THAT ARE
LANGUAGE AND CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE- PROCESS SOMETHING
ELSE ON MY MIND JUST WENT.
BLANK ON ME SO I WILL SEE IF
ANYBODY ELSE HAS ANY QUESTIONS
AT THIS TIME DR PAM. THANK YOU
AND AT FIRST- JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON THE WORK FORCE ISSUE- THE
PIPELINE OR ANY HEALTH
PROFESSIONS ACTUALLY RATHER
LONG SO I'D- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE. PEOPLE'S DESIRE TO
BUILD OUT THE PIPELINE BUT- BUT
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE MORE IMMEDIATE WORKFORCE
ISSUES ARE WE LOOKING AT FOR
EXAMPLE- HEY WORKING
CONDITIONS- ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONS LIKE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE OUT
THERE- WE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
ENGAGE THEM. ARE THEY REMAKING
A TRACTOR FOR THEM TO COME TO
WORK R. TWO YOU KNOW IT'S
BETTER- ARE WE ABLE TO RECRUIT
OTHER PLACES BECAUSE WE'RE IF
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FOR
TRAINING PIPELINE WE'RE TALKING
OF THE HOUSE. YOU KNOW YEARS
AND YEARS LATER. MAR DEL FIVE
FIVE PLUS YEARS LATER SO THAT
IS THERE BEEN SOME ASSESSMENT
OF- MAYBE LOOKING AT LICENSING
DATA AND SO FORTH AS TO HOW
MANY. MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS HAVE OUT THERE
AND DO WHAT DEGREE OR SOME OF
THEM PERHAPS NOT ACTUALLY
ACTIVELY IN PRACTICE AND THE
REASONS WHY A- HARDER GOING
RETIREMENT SITS AT OUR- SO- IS
THIS. IS THERE ANY SORT OF
ASSESSMENT THAT NATURE BEING
DONE. SO I'M A TRIDENT. TO SOME
OF THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY DOING.
AN ASSESSMENT AND A GAP
ANALYSIS THAT DOES INCLUDE SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS WHAT WE ARE
FINDING IS ACTUALLY IN THE
PUBLIC. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM WE DO HAVE A
HIGHER CONCENTRATION OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH LANGUAGE
SKILLS AND- ETHNIC RACE AND
ETHNIC. DIVERSITY THAN THE THAN
THE ACTUAL PIPELINE SO THOSE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DO TEND TO
COME TO OUR DELIVERY SYSTEM
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. PART OF THE
PROJECT THAT WE ARE DOING IS
RUNNING FOCUS GROUPS OF WITH
OUR ACTUAL CONDITIONS TO TALK
TO THEM ABOUT RETENTION AND
WHAT ARE THE IMPORTANT FACTORS
CONTRIBUTING TO- MAKING SURE
THAT THEY STAY WITHIN OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEM. SO WE ARE
LOOKING TO THOSE ANSWERS
UNFORTUNATELY I WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO GIVE THEM TO YOU NOW WE
ENGAGED IN A YEARLONG PROCESS
WITH UCS AFTER TO TRY TO
QUANTIFY SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION. OKAY AND PERHAPS I
DON'T KNOW- WHO AT THE STAKES I
KNOW I SPOT PERHAPS ISN'T ON
THE CALL BUT- KIND OF MEDICAL
OR IN THE- MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
AND HIS- HAS THERE BEEN A- MORE
GENERAL ASSESSMENT OF. THE WORK
FORCE IN A WAY TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT ARE WE ABLE TO BETTER ABLE
TO MOBILIZE OUR- OUR ALL OUR
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ALL
NOW RIGHT NOW WORKING FULL TIME
COMPLETE AND I REALIZE PEOPLE
HAVE INDIVIDUAL CHOICES THEY
MAKE TO SELL. IN TERMS OF THEIR
CAREERS- BUT- YEAH WE'LL SEE IF
THAT WE WAIT FOR THE PIPELINE
IT'S GOING TO BE HERE SO WHAT
WHAT CAN WE MOBILIZE MORE
IMMEDIATELY. FOR THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. AS A RANSOM ASSESSMENT
OF THATDO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE
FAKE. THE- RETIRING MAYBE NEAR
RETIREMENT MIGHT COME BACK-
WORKING PART TIME MAYBE GIVEN
THE STEP UP HOURS. SORRY
SENATOR PAD WE WOULD ADD THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT WOULD NEED TO
DEPEND ON THE HOSPITAL PROBABLY
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS THEY
NEED A LOT OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE EFFORTS IN THE
STATE AND SO. I WOULD NEED TO
WORK WITH THEM TO GET YOUR
RESPONSE FROM FROM THE STATE
ALL RIGHT SO IT'S A TIGHT SO
AGAIN WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
WORKFORCE I KEEP HEARING ABOUT
PIPELINE AND BELIEVE ME I
BELIEVE IN PIPELINE BUT- THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. NOW THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT-
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY I WAS AT THE
VILLAGE B. DO A- INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON MENTAL HEALTH
INNOVATIONS- THAT WAS SPONSORED
BY STEINBERG INSTITUTE SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN LOOK AT SOME
OF THOSE THINGS BUT IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO STAND UP. RECOGNIZING
THAT YOU KNOW DO YOU WANT SOME
TIME TO WORK ON THINGS AND I DO
WANT TO JUST REINFORCE WHAT-
THEY'LL CHILDREN NOW SAID WE
HAVE WE HAVE AN EXISTING FIRE
AS AS WELL SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
LOOK AT. WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT
SOME OF THE KIDS NOW WHAT WE
HAVE FOR THAT DAY WE LIKE TO
SAY SHOVEL READY WE TALK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THIS KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MIGHT BE
SHOVEL READY- EXAM ROOM READY-OR WHATEVER BUT- IN ADDITION TO
THAT- ARE THERE SOME COMPONENTS
THAT PERHAPS WE CAN STAND UP
MORE QUICKLY TALK ABOUT THINGS.
LIKE- ECON SOLD- EIGHT- YOU
KNOW I. OUT OF THE TO TALK.
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
TRAINING. FOR SCHOOL STAFF BUT-
EVEN LET'S SAY ON THE ECON SOLD
SIR. IS IT POSSIBLE TO. SEE
THINK ABOUT HOW QUICKLY WE CAN
STAND UP THERE. AND HE CALLED.
THE PROVIDING BASICALLY- MENTAL
HEALTH DIRECT CONSULTATION TO
BUILD SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS THESE
MODELS ARE OUT THERE- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON TELEHEALTH-
THROUGHOUT THE PERIOD. PANDEMIC
DO YOU THINK THE THOSE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME OPPONENTS WHO CAN
STAND UP MORE QUICKLY- THAT- SO
I. APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF LIKE
SITTING BACK AND FIGURE OUT
THIS WHOLE SYSTEM AT CETERA BUT
MAYBE THERE'S SOME COMPONENTS
THAT WE KNOW THE PART OF SYSTEM
WE CAN STAND UP MORE QUICKLY-
TO TRY TO. PROVIDE. MORE ACCESS
TO SERVICES MORE IMMEDIATELY.
WHAT WHAT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
IT'S GOING TO DEPEND WILL HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS AND HAPPY TO ENGAGE
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO A
STATEWIDE. THE CONSOLE PLATFORM
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT WILL
HAVE TO ENGAGE IN A
PROCUREMENT- A COMPETITIVE CAN
PROBE HIM AT PROCUREMENT FOR
THE SERVICES. AND THEN LINKING
TO A STATEWIDE NETWORK THOSE
THINGS TYPICALLY DON'T HAPPEN
VERY QUICKLY- IT WE DO NEED
TIME TO KIND OF. CONSULT WITH
PEOPLE AND DO THE ANALYTICS TO
THE PROCUREMENT AND- I GET I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD JUST SAY IS
THAT DESERVE MORE DYNAMIC WAY
OF THINKING ABOUT SO I GET THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU WILL
CREATE A STATEWIDE- NOW. AND I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT OF THAT BUT
AS WE'RE BUILDING UP TO THAT
STATE WIDE NETWORK IS THERE A
WAY TO START RECRUITING MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO PROVIDE
ECON SOLD. USING EXISTING
PLATFORMS MORE IMMEDIATELY AND
THEN ROLL THEM UP INTO A
STATEWIDE YOU KNOW I. T.
PLATFORMS WITH BUILT. SEVENTY
THAT DOES REQUIRE PROCUREMENT
AND SO FORTH. BUT THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE BUILD SOME OF THIS
STUFF A LITTLE BIT PARALLEL
RAKES SO WE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO MIGHT BE ABLE
TO- YOU KNOW. USING SOME.
CERTAIN PLACES SOME REASON.
SOME EXISTING PLATFORMS
ETCETERA SAID WE'VE BEEN
BUILDING OUT SOME TELEHEALTH
STUFF SO FAR MAYBE THERE'S- SO
IT JUST WANTED TO. THINK A
LITTLE MORE CREATIVELY IN TERMS
OF. HOW DO WE TRY TO. GET
SERVICES TO PEOPLE MORE QUICKLY
AND ACTUALLY EVEN AND IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING SOME OF THESE
OTHER THINGS. WE'RE GOING TO
SERVE THESE ARE ALMOST LIKE
PILOTY TYPE THINGS BECAUSE
MAYBE LEARN SOMETHING THAT MAY
BE USEFUL AS WE BUILD OUT THE
LARGER STATEWIDE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST SOME OF
THESE THINGS OUT AND- ON A
SMALLER SCALE PERHAPS BUT-
USING EXISTING PLATFORMS. YES
SO I THINK- IT'S GOING TO BE-
SO THERE ARE SOME OF THE PIECES
BUT THEN THE PROPOSAL DO YOU
START- EARLIER RIGHT. A LOT OF
THE WORK FORCE INFRASTRUCTURE
STARTS BEFORE THAT. VIRTUAL
PLATFORM HAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT WOULD LAUNCH TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE WORK FORCE. MARKET YOU
KNOW. MOVING FORWARD AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. ON THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE SCHOOLING
TO GRANTS WOULD GO UP EARLIER-
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOUR BUILDING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND- CONNECTING THE PLANS TO
THE SCHOOLS. WOULD BE YOU KNOW
IN ADVANCE TO LAUNCHING KIND OF
THE STATE WIDE NETWORKS OF
THOSE PIECES WOULD BE HAPPENING
PRIOR TO YOU. AS WELL AS-
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE GRANTS
SO IDENTIFYING WHICH EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES WE WANT TO- YOU
KNOW SPREAD AND EXPAND
STATEWIDE WOULD BE ABLE TO.
FOLLOW THOSE DOLLARS IN ADVANCE
TO THAT KIND OF STATE OR
STATEWIDE PLATFORM. AND THEN.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I THINK
THAT THEY HAVE A WHOLE
CONTINUUM. WHERE WE'RE NEEDING
THE ACTUAL. BRICK AND MORTAR
PIECES THOSE WOULD BE STARTING
IN ADVANCE OF A LOT OF BLIND.
SHE ARE GOING TO. PRIOR TO THE
START. THAT FOUNDATION THAT
BASE. GETTING THE INVESTMENT
OUT STATEWIDE. TO EVENTUALLY
THEN TAP INTO THAT INTO THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORMS OF WHERE
THOSE DIRECT SERVICES CAN BE
PROVIDED THE LINKS AND THE-
CONNECTIONS TO. THOSE REFERRALS
BUT WE'LL DEFINITELY TAKE THAT
FEEDBACK BACK IN REGARDS TO
YOU. EVEN SOME OF THE- YOU KNOW
YOU CONSUL IN OTHER PIECES HOW
CAN MEAN BABY. LEVERAGE THAT
AND GET THEM UP SOONER SO WE
CAN WE CAN TAKE THAT BACK AND
HAVE SOME. ANTIQUE ABOUT THAT.
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN
ALSO YOU TALK ABOUT THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN I ASSUME
THAT SOMETHING YOU CAN EARLIER
THAN LATER- BECAUSE- IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO ADDRESS THE STIGMA
ISSUES ANY OTHER ISSUES. THAT
IS CORRECT OKAY. AND THEN AND
THEN I THINK I THINK AND JUST
WANT TO REINFORCE SOMETHING
THAT- CHAIR EDMUND SAID IS
THAT- CERTAINLY VERY EXCITED.
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT BUT
ALSO BE SURE WE- TAYLOR
EXPECTATIONS IN A WAY THAT WE
DON'T SEE- SET EXPECTATIONS
WHERE PEOPLE BECOME
DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE IT'S GONNA
BE REALLY HARD TO GET PEOPLE TO
COME BACK IF THEY FEEL
DISAPPOINTED UP IN THE
BEGINNING SO I'M NOT. WE WANT
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING WE WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THAT THERE'S HELP WE NEED TO BE
SURE WE CAN MEET THAT NEED AND-
WHEN WAS WE AS AS WE'RE DOING
THIS BUT WE NEED TO DO IT IN A
WAY SOTHAT- WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE. ARE GETTING FRUSTRATED
AND THEN WALKING AWAY AND THEN
WE WONDER WHY DON'T SHOW UP
LATER WHEN WE ARE READY- SO WE
HAVE THAT THAT'S GONNA BE
CAREFUL PART OF THAT THE- THE
MANAGEMENT EXPECTATIONS AS
WELL. TO BE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE COMMUNITIES
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED HELP
AND KNOW THAT THEY CAN GET
HELP. BUT AT THE LEVEL WHICH
WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO PROVIDE
IT- AS MUCH AS WE WANT TO HELP
MAYBE ONE TO HELP THE MORE- BUT
JUST JUST BE SURE TO BRING THAT
AND THEN AGAIN I JUST WANT
REINFORCE WHAT CHILDREN NOW
SAID WE DO HAVE SOME I SAID
THAT PERHAPS EXAM ROOM READY
THINGS THAT WE- MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT. BE SURE WE CAN
ROLL OUT SO THAT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING PEOPLE ON HOLD AS WELL
SO IT'S KIND OF THE BALANCE OF
EXPECTATION AND SERVICE. THANK
YOU. THE YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR PAN. YEAH AND I
WOULD I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
WE'RE MOVING INTO THE
SUMMERTIME ON SCHOOLS GET READY
TO GET OUT- SOME SOME HAVEN'T
START ALL THE WAY YET AND SO AS
WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. I WOULD JUST.
ECHO THE URGENCY OF SENATOR PAN
IN. MAKING SURE WE HAVE
WHATEVER WE DO WHATEVER WE CAN
PUT TOGETHER RIGHT NOW FOR
SUMMER MONTHS- WHETHER THAT'S A
TWO ONE ONE SYSTEM THE COUNTIES
ARE USING IN SOME PLACES OR- I
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF WE COULD.
USE A MY TURN FOR SOME THINGS
THAT WE'RE THINKING ABOUT TOO
BUT ANYWAY. THE FASTER ACCESS
WE CAN GET AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S HELP OUT THERE FOR
PEOPLE AS WE GO INTO THE SUMMER
MONTHS. THIS IMPORTANT.
QUESTION FOR MANY OTHER
SENATORS AT AT THIS TIME. THE
MANAGER MIGHT RESPOND TO
SENATOR PAM THIS IS TOBY DOING.
THIS GUEST MISTREATMENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TOOK EVEN WITH
MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSION. I
WANTED TO- MENTIONED THAT
YOU'RE- ON THE WORK FORCE ISSUE
IN CALL AND RESPONSE TO STATE
IT'S PHENOMENAL WORK TO
ACTIVATE THE ENTIRE WORK FORCE
THAT WAS AVAILABLE LAST SENATOR
PAN SAID. AND WE DID HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ACTIVATING
THE MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE. IN
SOME EMERGENCY TYPE STATUS YET
IN A SIMILAR STRATEGY TO WHAT
WAS DONE WITH NURSES
RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS- I DO
WANT TO REFERENCE THAT. AS WAS
BENCHED BY CHILDREN NOW-
COUNTIES ACTUALLY ARE READY TO
GO WITH IF THERE'S- ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE MEDICAL STUDENT
SERVICES ACT. AND NEARLY EAT
NEARLY ALL OF THOSE COUNTIES
THAT ARE UNDER FUNDED. HAVE
PROPOSED USING A PORTION OF
THOSE FUNDS. TO DO MENTAL
HEALTH SCREENS FOR STUDENTS AND
THIS COULD BE A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN. ABOUT HOW
TO BUILD OUT AND SCALE
SCREENING IN A WAY THAT COULD
FEED INTO THE BROADER PLAN TO
GET MINISTRATION HAS IN MIND. I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
CAL HOPE WEBSITE. DOES HAVE A
COMPONENT OF DIGITAL TOOLS. FOR
CALIFORNIANS ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. IT'S A VERY SMALL
INVESTMENT THAT THE COMMISSION
MADE CONSISTENT WITH SOME
FUNDING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FOUNDATION. AND
FEMA FUNDS. IT'S SO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ELEMENTS THE WARM.
HERE SUPPORT AFTER. THE SOCIAL.
LEARNING INVESTMENTS THAT WERE
MADE TO THE FEMA GRANT THAT
COULD BE BUILT UPON SOME OF
THAT IS INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL SO THAT SENATOR
SENATOR PAM SAYS WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME THINGS IN
PLACE OVER THE SUMMER. THAT
WOULD ALLOW THESE PARTNERSHIPS
AND THESE EFFORTS TO. BE THERE
WHEN STUDENTS WALK BACK ON
CAMPUS. EDITION ONLY THEY ALSO
COULD PROVIDE AID THE RIGHT
KIND OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO FRAME
OUT. WHAT THE BROADER PROPOSAL
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DISCUSSING WHAT LOOK LIKE
OVERTIME. THANK YOU FOR THE
CHANCE TO MAKE THAT COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
EWING OKAY AND I THINK YOU JILL
TO STAY ON BECAUSE- ON OUR LAST
ISSUE- THE ISSUE FOUR SIX. FOUR
FIVE SIX ZERO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS WHICH HAS
TO DO WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. ABSOLUTELY SO THAT
THERE ARE TWO ISSUES IN THE
TECHNICAL ADVANCEMENTS IN
ESSENCE WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS AN
EXTENDED TIME FRAME TO. ALLOW
CAN'T SOME OF OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO CONTINUE TO USE
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
THE COMMISSION AND THE PRIOR
FISCAL YEAR. AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED COUNTIES HAVE FACED A
NUMBER OF BARRIERS AS HAVE WE
ALL HERE AND BEING ABLE TO
RESPOND TO NEEDS AND SO THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS. IN
ESSENCE ARE TO ALLOW A LONGER
TIME FRAME FOR COUNTIES TO
UTILIZE SOME OF THEIR SPD TO
FINES. AND TO SUPPORT A MULTI
COUNTY INNOVATION COLLABORATIVE
THAT IS DESIGNED TO EXPLORE THE
USE OF PSYCHIATRIC ADVANCE
DIRECTIVES AS A STRATEGY TO
REDUCE RELIANCE ON CRISIS
SERVICES AND ULTIMATELY REDUCE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT
AND STATE HOSPITAL INVOLVEMENT.
THROUGH BETTER UPSTREAM
ENGAGEMENT WITH PEERS WHO ARE
AT HIGH RISK OF NEEDING CRISIS
SERVICES SO THOSE TO TACKLE
JUST SPENDS ARE TO ALLOW THAT
WORK TO CONTINUE. OKAY DENISON
DOES MAKE SENSE WE THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS AT THIS TIME.
OKAY AND WE WILL BE HOLDING ALL
OF THESE ITEMS OPENER ALL
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATIONS-
AT THIS TIME WE WILL MOVE ON IF
NO MEMBERS HAVE ANYTHING
FURTHER TO ADD TO THIS. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO- ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
THERE MIGHT BE. I DO NOT
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYBODY IN ROME
TWENTY FORTY ONE BUT WE CAN
LOOK OVER THERE TWENTY FORTY.
YUP THERE WE GO. OKAY A
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. I AM
HERE THANKS VERY MUCH HE WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO MAC
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU LET US KNOW HOW MANY ARE IN
THE QUEUE MYSTERON RAIDER.
RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
TEN PEOPLE IN QUEUE. AND ARE
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN LOVE THANK YOU MATT. I
THANK THE MEMBERS WERE HAVING
THIS HEARING MY NAME IS
BEGINNING COLBERN I'M THE CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND
I'M- PROVIDING COMMENTS ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE CHILD CARE.
OUR COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
RECORDED THANKS ALL AND OUR
LOWEST INCOME FAMILIES WITH
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE AND OTHER
FAMILIES THE COURT. STARTED THE
PANDEMIC ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS WERE IMMEDIATELY
TASKED WITH GETTING MONEY OUT
FOR PPP AND TYPE IN FOR
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS THE
LONELINESS AND SHOW WORKERS.
IT'S BEEN ROLLING AND THEN RE
ENROLLING OR CONTINUING. AGENCY
STEPPED UP TO IMPLEMENT THE
PANDEMIC RELATED MANDATES
WITHOUT MEANINGFUL FUNDING AT
FIVE MACAU WORKS PROGRAM THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF VOUCHERS WITH
ROUGHLY SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
SENATE PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDCARE
SLOTS THE MAJORITY OF WHICH IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE ABOUT
VOUCHERS. OUR COMMUNITY
EIGHTIES MUST BE FUNDED WITH
MONEY TO GET THE FAMILY
CONTROLLED AS THE CURRENT
FUNDING MODEL OF A PIECE IS
ONLY BASED ON MONIES THAT GO
OUT THE DOOR TO A PROVIDER. ONE
CHOSEN BY A FAMILY THIS FUNDING
MODEL DOES NOT ALLOW THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO BEGIN TO
RAMP UP. TO MEET THE
ANTICIPATED AND NEEDED A ROMAN
FAMILY AND IN OUR EXPERIENCE
ROUGHLY ONE THIRD OF THE
FAMILIES THAT BEGIN THE CHILD
CARE ENROLLMENT PROCESS DO NOT
COMPLETE. UTILIZATION OF ONE
TIME MONIES ALLOCATED TO
AGENCIES TO BEGIN HIRING AND
TRAINING CASE MANAGER AND
ENROLLMENT SPECIALISTS WOULD BE
A GREAT INVESTMENT. I ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS EXPRESSED THAT THE
T. K. PROPOSAL DOES JEOPARDIZE
THE PARENTAL CHOICE THE CHILD
CARE. FOR THEIR CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT THERE BE NO
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
ASIDE FROM THE ABOVE WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR SUPPORT- WITH
ISSUES RAISED BY THE ECB
COALITION AND LIFT UP THE
REIMBURSEMENT ABOUT THAT OF OUR
VALUES FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE. AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. ALAINA
ONE SO EIGHT. THANK YOU
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER ON BEHALF
OF THE AD YEAH YOU AS WELL AS
AS A U. N. U. W. V. P.
ORGANIZATION. I WANT TO COMMENT
ON THE CHILDCARE ISSUE AND I
HAVE A COMMENT- BUT HOLLY PRYOR
IN THE PANELISTS AND THAT WE
NEED TO STABILIZE OUR PROVIDERS
WE'VE SEEN. A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN THE AMOUNT OF. I
WORKFORCE WE ARE CONCERNED WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A NEED WE
HAVE TWO MILLION CHILDREN ARE
QUALIFIED OR NOT. AND WE WERE
EXCITED IS THE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND I COULD BE A LONG TERM
PLAN TO GETTING YOUR CHILDREN
IN. HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
AROUND THE G. CAPABLE AS IT.
OPENED THE REST TO CHILD CARE
IF WE ARE TO MOVE FORWARD I
WOULD REALLY URGE
CONSIDERATION. AND THAT WE
ENSURE THAT OUR RATES ARE
STABILIZED BUT THE CHILD- ZERO
THREE ARE ALSO PRIORITIZED. AND
OTHER PROVIDERS ARE LISTED OUT
AND ARE SUPPORTED BY THE STATE
WE HAVE A NUMBER HELLO THAT I
CAN SHARE OFF LINE THAT WE HAVE
AN- IMPORTANT SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN BOWL. I DON'T WANT TO
PUT UP LEVEL AND THE MARGIN
LEVEL I REPRESENT ANY AIRPORT-
AND THEN ON THE P. OR I'D
MENTAL HEALTH WE ARE REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE INVESTMENT.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT NEEDS CALL
CARE WHOLE PERSON CARE
ANTICIPATING THAT- WE OPERATE
HIGHLY THAT WE HAVE A REAL
CRISIS IN THE COMING OF OUR
SCHOOLS. AND CHILDREN ARE IN
THIRTY FOUR THEY ARE A GREATER
RISK FOR. BOTH POLITICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SO WE
WOULD URGE AN INVESTMENT IN THE
QATARI- STAFF HAD TO CLIMB IN.
THE RECESSION AND HAS NOT BEEN
RESTOCKED EVEN THOUGH THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF BOTH SCHOOLS
HAVE INCREASED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE HI. NINETY
FIVE. LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE YOU'RE MY KIDS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. LET'S MOVE ON
THOMAS MODERATE. ALLIED TWO
HUNDRED TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND THEN I'M GONNA BE
OUT HERE ALSO ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA BUT- THE GREETING ON
THE STUDENT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROPOSAL PRESENTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THEN YESTERDAY WE
GOT A REVISED INVESTMENT. FUND
THE PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE
INCENTIVE PAYMENT DIRECTED TO
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY FOR THE
PROVISION OF KOBE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES WE WOULD ECHO
AND ALIGN OURSELVES WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE AL YEAH DIAGONAL FROM
EVGA. INSURER COUNTY SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN CAN ACCESS
WE'VE BEEN SENT A PAYMENT ONCE
WE TRANSITION OUR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PAYMENT WITH THEM AS
OPPOSED TO AN ACCOUNTING ISSUE
THEN AND TO ALSO BUILD OUT OUR
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS THE WEB
PROGRAM AND LASTLY- TO ACTUALLY
HIRE CLINICALLY TRAINED AND
ALSO CERTIFIED INDIVIDUALS SUCH
AS CARE SPECIALIST SO THAT OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
ARE. FURTHER. SUPPLEMENTED AND
EXPANDED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN AND THEN- PANCHAL
THE QUESTION ON THE IN THE AND
LONG TERM BACK. WORKING CAN AND
PAY PIPELINE PROGRAM. WE HAVE
THE SAME QUESTION AND IN THE
PAST IT WAS A LITTLE A FUNDING.
BUT NOW THAT THERE IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR NEW RESOURCES
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL CAN
ACTUALLY GO TOWARD HIRING AND
SALARY. CENTER AT MINNESOTA
PENN YOU'RE BOTH ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE NEED TO HIRE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
NOW. THEY'RE READY BY JULY ONE
OF THIS YEAR AND ONE SCORED
FORTY OPEN WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME BUILDING OUT THAT DATA
PLATFORM AND PROVIDER NETWORK.
I'VE CONTEMPLATED IN THE OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
BECAUSE THOSE THAT WE NEED FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD I
TELL YOU IS READY TO RECRUIT
RETAIN AND HIRE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL. OUR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE THE
BEST AND MOST SKILLED AND
TRUSTED PROVIDER BY THOSE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND ASK YOU
THE SERVICE THAT. EVERYONE A
LIFT UP THEIR CENTRAL ROLE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH
YOU ALL ON THE GAS SERVICES.
EQUITY NEEDS AND ALSO WORK FOR
THE- ENGINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLOR PLEASE. BLIND A.
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
PORTABLE CHARGER CREEK THE
BILLION OPENS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES MY NAME IS KIND OF
LIKE A LITTLE CHILD CARE CENTER
YEAH THANK YOU HI ONE THE WAY
FAMILY FEUD FOR ALL FAMILIES
THIS IS AMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
OBLIGATE AND EXPAND AND EXPAND
THE FEDERAL CHILD CARE THROUGH
THE ADDITION GRANT WHICH IS TWO
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT CALIFORNIA GOT AND- AT
REFERENCING THE GUIDANCE ISSUED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ON MAY TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CHALKY PLEADING TO
ONE MILLION IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WHICH IS ABOUT. TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. THE
RACE OF THE RACE FOR CHOCOLATE.
WHICH IS WHY HUNDRED THIRTY.
FOUR THIRTY MILLION AND THAT
FOR ANY PARTICULAR PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
PARENTS TO CHOOSE THE SETTING
OF THEIR CHOICE. A COMMUNITY
CENTER FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME OR
FAMILY. CARE WE ASKED FOR A
PAUSE ON THE PEACEKEEPER CALLED
ON TO ALLOW FOR A STAKEHOLDER
INPUT MOWBRAY'S SETTINGS AND
EXPERTISE. DEVISE A
COMPREHENSIVE CHILDCARE PROGRAM
THAT WORKS. WITH FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
BLINDED TWO HUNDRED SEVEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ASHLEY PUT THE- BELOIT PUBLIC
POLICY SPECIALIST FOR CHILD
THREE SIXTY I WANT TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH CHILDCARE PANELISTS
COMMENTS IN CALLING FOR
INCREASED REIMBURSEMENT RATES
ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE SPACES
INVESTMENT HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AND THE WEAVING A
FAMILY THING I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTING IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR EASY
PROFESSIONAL. NEARLY SEVERAL
SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
DESIGNATED FOR THIS PURPOSE
WERE PREVIOUSLY SWEPT YOU TO
COPE AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
INSTALLERS BE RESTORED TO
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL THE TOPICS
SUCH AS TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
HOW TO BECOME EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC EASY PROFESSIONAL CAN
ALSO BENEFIT FROM THE SUPPORT
OF COACHES IT CAN BE A SOUNDING
BOARD AND THE PROFESSIONALS
WITH INSTRUCTIONAL TECHNIQUES
FAMILY OUTREACH STRATEGIES. AS
MORE CHILDREN. RETURNED TO THE
CLASSROOM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR. HELLO THIS
IS BRENDA BROWN I AM ACTUALLY-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ONE OF
THOSE PRIVATE NON- PROFIT-
CENTER BASED CARE PROGRAMS WE
ARE ONE OF THE REAL PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY STAYED OPEN ANSWER AND
SERVED IN PERSON AND ARE
CONTINUING TO DO SO IN THAT
LIGHT I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
SOMETHING THAT IT WAS IT WAS
TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE BIT BUT I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU BRING
IT UP AND- HOLD HARMLESS CLAUSE
THAT MEAN ABILITY HAD
MENTIONED. REMEMBER THAT
NOTHING RIGHT NOW RIGHT IF WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HOLD HARMLESS
AND HAS BEEN A GODSEND TO US
THIS ENTIRE YEAR BECAUSE THE IN
HOSTILITY TO SERVE OUR ENTIRE
CONTRACT OR THE COST OF OUR
CONTRACT IT IS FLUCTUATING
BECAUSE OF THE GUIDELINES WITH
HOW WOULD WE NEED TO CONTINUE
WE NEED TO JUST BE ABLE TO SAY
HEY IF WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE FUNDING. FOR HOW WE
CAN SERVE I HAVE TO PAY MY
TEACHERS MORE I'VE LOST
WORKFORCE EITHER DUE TO COPE
WITH IT- RESTRICTIONS OR JUST
BECAUSE OF THEIR FEARS FOR
WORKING AND I CAN'T HIRE PEOPLE
I NEED MORE MONEY TO HIRE
PEOPLE THEY'RE GONNA BE
REQUIRING. MORE MONEY TO WORK-
WE'RE NOT WE DON'T LOSE ANY
PROGRAM WE DON'T. ANY US THAT
ARE SERVING HALF CLOSE. VERY
VERY IMPORTANT THINGS AND THEN
IT'S ONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS. WHO
IS NAVIGATING THIS WHOLE
TRANSITION- TO THE SS I HAVE
BOTH TYPES OF PROGRAMS I'M
STAYING IN CD AND BRING THE DSL
SO THAT WHOLE PART MUCH AS THEY
CAN. WE WERE IMPORTANT TO ME TO
JUST FIGURE OUT HOW TO EVEN
MANAGE THIS ENTIRE YEAR. AND
THEN WE REALLY REALLY NEED OUR
REIMBURSEMENT RIGHT WAY OUT IT
IS SO. IT'S ALSO BEHIND AND WE
CONTINUE TO BE BEHIND IN THIS
LITTLE ONE POINT FIVE COLORS IS
NOTHING IF NOT NOT ANYTHING
COMPARED TO WHAT THEY CALL THE
THINGS ARE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
HEARING ME AND- I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO THIRD AND CONTINUE
TO. INCREASE MY AND MY SERVICES
TO FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY WE
HAVE A HUGE WEIGHTLESS WE'VE
BEEN OPEN SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO AND PROVIDE
QUALITY QUALITY CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
POLITE AT. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
HACKED AND I WORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE
WHERE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ISSUES AND DRINKING WATER
SAFETY ACCESS AND EDUCATION
TWENTY FOURTEEN. I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO BUDGET FOR ACCESS TO
STATE AND APPEALING DRINKING
WATER FOR CHILDREN IN CHILDCARE
AND IN SCHOOL. WE HAVE A DUAL
PANDEMIC BOTH COVERT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS OF DIET RELATED
DISEASES SUCH AS TYPE TWO
DIABETES OBESITY AND
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE. EITHER
INTER RELATED BECAUSE THE TOP
CHRONIC CONDITIONS ARE ALSO
RISK FACTORS FOR SEVERE COLD
CASES SHOULD CONDITION COST OUR
STATE MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN HEALTH CARE ANNUALLY. I
TALKED TO TRY TO G. TO OVERCOME
THESE IS BY REDUCING THE
CONSUMPTION OF ADDED SUGARS.
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF ADDED
SUGARS IN THE DIET IS SUGARY
DRINKS. WHEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT SAN FRANCISCO
BANNED SUGARY DRINK SALES THEY
THOUGHT MARKET. IMPROVEMENT IN
HEALTH INDICATORS. BUT IF WE
WANT FOLKS TO DROPSHIP DRINKS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN ACCESS DRINKING WATER THAT
IS BOTH SAFE AND APPEALING
WHICH IS IN LINE WITH OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO WATER AT
THE HUMAN RIGHT. SO WHAT'S MAKE
A ONE TIME INVESTMENT AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY SCHOOL HAS AT
LEAST ONE WATER BOTTLE FILLING
STATION. CDPH ESTIMATES AT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
INSTALLATION MANY SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY THERE WE SHOULD GET THE
REST OF THEM TO THAT. SAME
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. THAT WAY
KIDS CAN GET MORE THAN THAT.
THANK GOD IT WITHOUT SPREADING
DISEASE. CHILDCARE PLEASE ADD
TO THE BUDGET FOR LEAD
MITIGATION AND CLIMBING TO MAKE
OUR NEW BLOOD TESTING PROGRAM
UNDER A B. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
THE FACT. BUDGET INVESTMENTS IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND SAFETY
SHOULD INCLUDE EASY ACCESS TO
STATE AN APPEALING TAP WATER IN
OUR SCHOOL AND CHILD CARE.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF I CAN
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE YOU MY- INPUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. LINE FORTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS I'M CALLING
REGARDING THE CHILD CARE ISSUE
MY NAME IS ANDREA FERNANDEZ AND
I'M THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S ACADEMY
WE SERVE INFANTS TODDLERS AND
PRESCHOOLERS AND FIFTEEN CENTER
BASED ON SCHOOLS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY UNLIKE BRENDA WE'VE ALSO
BEEN OPENED THE ENTIRE PANDEMIC
SERVING THE LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OF LOS ANGELES- I'M CALLING
JUST TO ALSO ECHO THE SUPPORT-
THE STATEMENT OF THE CHILDCARE
PANELIST NINA BOOTY. AND THAT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ALL OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE CITY WE
SUPPORT RATE REFORM AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE REALLY NEED THE
HOLD HARMLESS FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- IT'S
ALREADY ALLOCATED IN THE BUDGET
IT WILL HELP PROGRAMS LIKE OURS
STAY OPEN AND RUNNING IN SO
MANY OF YOU KNOW HAVE ALREADY
SHUT DOWN. AGAIN ALSO THE RATE
REFORM WILL ALSO HELP
SIGNIFICANTLY WE ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME FINDING TEACHERS TO
COME YOU KNOW TO AND WORK IN
OUR PROGRAMS LIKE I SAID WE'VE
BEEN OPEN AND THAT'S REALLY
HELPED US STAY OPEN BUT- IT WE
FACED SOME SIGNIFICANT BATTLES
AHEAD IF WE DON'T HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE C. E. SO THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE WE APPRECIATE ALL
YOU'VE DONE OVER THE ENTIRE
PANDEMIC FOR EASY AND- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. A LINE OF. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE. HI MY NAME IS SUE
BRIDGMAN ON ANY DAY AFTER OF
THE PROGRAM IN BERKELEY STEP
ONE SCHOOL TEACHER. I YOUR.
BRITAIN ME. OKAY SOME QUICK.
PROVIDER BOTH. HI IT QUICKLY.
J. I. RAIDER WERE HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING THAT PARTICULAR
CALL OR- OKAY- THE CALL WENT IN
AND OUT OF FOR US AND SO WE GOT
THE GIST FROM THE BEGINNING AND
THE CALLER WISHES TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS ARE TOO LOOSE
TODAY THEIR COMMENTS THEY CAN
DO THAT THEN WE COULD GO ON TO
THE NEXT CALLER. A LINE OF. ONE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT. HELLO
THIS IS ROBIN LAYTON ON
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
EDUCATIONAL MATCHING THEM IN
SAN DIEGO WHAT A NONPROFIT
CENTER BASED ORGANIZATION WE
HAVE TWENTY TWO PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE CENTERS SERVING
INFANTS TODDLERS AND THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLD. WE ALSO EMPLOY A
HUNDRED AND NINETY- WONDERFUL
AMAZING CHILDCARE WORKERS. I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WENT BEFORE ME.
AND FAST BUT THAT- THE HOLD
HARMLESS. FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO HE CONTINUED. ALSO GREAT
REFORM IS- IT IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO PAY THE PROFESSIONAL
WAGE THAT OUR CHILD CARE
WORKERS DON'T DESERVE AS YOU'VE
HEARD ME FROM OUR COLLEAGUES.
AND OUR PROGRAM HE STAYED OPEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND WILL
CONTINUE TO STAY OPEN FOR IN
PERSON LEARNING. ARE ALSO
OFFERING DISTANCE LEARNING. FOR
ALL OF THE AGE GROUP AND IT'S
ACTUALLY ALLOWING FOR- A LOT OF
FAMILY SUPPORT FOR THE FAMILIES
THAT ARE IN DIRE STRAITS SO
THEY'RE THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WERE SERVING THEM AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR MY
ORGANIZATION ARE ALSO THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. I ALSO WANT
TO REITERATE THAT- FOUR YEAR
OLD. THEY BELONG IN OUR CURRENT
MAKE BELIEVE THAT- VERY MUCH
NEEDS ALL DAY ALL DAY AND-
LEVIN HOURS NOT SIX HOURS.
AROUND TWELVE MONTHS OUT OF THE
YEAR CLOSED ON THE MAJOR
HOLIDAYS NOT COOL BEER AND SOME
ARE NOT FAMILY MEANS AND THAT
IS THE TRUE. FULL DAY YEAR
ROUND. I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT-
I REALLY APPRECIATE- DELIVERY.
THE SENATE AND THE COMMITTEE
WILL RESPECTING AND
APPRECIATING OUR TEACHERS WHO.
CAME TO WORK AND CONTINUE TO
COME TO WORK IN PERSON EVERY
SINGLE DAY ONE OTHER- WORKED
REMOTELY AND CONTINUE TO WORK
REMOTELY THEY THEY TRULY
DESERVE A PROFESSIONAL WAGE AND
RATE REFORM OPTICS THAT. AND
I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORDS THE
COURT TODAY. AND ALSO FOR YOUR
BUDGET PRIORITIES THAT WERE
SUBMITTED FROM THE PLANET THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE.
BLINDED. TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN.
HI THIS IS NEAR MORTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE MY CHILDREN NOW
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT THE
NEED TO AGGRESSIVELY INVEST
IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENTABLE
PROGRAMMES AND PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS THE URGENT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS FACING ARGUES AS
WELL AS A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO
HELP INCREASE ACCESS AND REDUCE
DISPARITIES OVER TIME. WE HAVE
A UNIQUE MOMENT WHERE THE STATE
HAS THE MEANS TO DO BOTH BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE FOR EACH PROPOSAL WHEN
WHERE AND HOW MUCH TO INVEST.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED EIGHTY
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN EXISTING SCHOOL
COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS AND WAITING
FOR FUNDING AND- THAT HAVE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS- AND WE
HAVE ALSO INTRODUCED OUR OWN
REQUEST FOR ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL. IMMEDIATELY INCREASE
ACCESS TO A RANGE OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN THEIR
REGIONS CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
ALSO HAS A SIMILAR REQUEST TO
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACROSS
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE. TOGETHER
THESE APPS HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS THE
OVERWHELMING NEED OUR CHILDREN
ARE EXPERIENCING AND WE HOPE
THE LEGISLATURE WILL CONSIDER
FUNDING ALL THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TEXT COLOR
PLEASE. BLINDED TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MAKING GETTING MALAYSIA
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE WITH CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES FIRST OFF
WE WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY CHILDREN NOW
HIGHLIGHTING THE URGENT NEED
THAT STUDENTS TODAY AN
IMMEDIATE ABILITY A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO PARTNER
WITH SCHOOLS AND PROVIDE
INTENSIVE INTERVENTION FOR
ABOUT OUT RESCUED IN AN
ARGUMENT. SHE NEED BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO EMBED EUROPEAN PROFESSIONAL
ON IT WHICH WILL CAMP AT THE
TOP OF HER STUDENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THE HOME OVER
SUMMER BREAK AND DURING NON
TRADITIONAL HOURS ARE PROVIDERS
KNOW HOW TO ENGAGE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND PROVIDE CRITICAL
SUPPORT YOUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
GORD BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATION- AND ALREADY
SUPPORTS LEARNING FAMILY TODAY
ADDITIONALLY THE WHOLE
PRODUCTION EFFORTS WOULD NOT
ONLY HELP MAINTAIN OUR EXISTING
WORKFORCE. BUT FREE UP
IMPORTANT CLINICAL TIME AND
ALLOW STAFF TO SPEND MORE TIME
SERVING FOR CLIENTS AND MEET
THE INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO CAN BE
THERE WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTED AT
THE CORE OF THE COALITION
REQUESTS FOR EIGHTY POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GRANTS THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN COOL
TURNING THE WHOLE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO STUDENTS THROUGH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION THE
KEY INVESTMENT IN SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND KEY PARTNERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FOR MEDICAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS IN COORDINATION WITH
PUBLIC HERE HOPE THE TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PARTNERSHIPS AND
CAPACITY THE WHITES TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
RECEIVING PREVENTATIVE AND
EARLY INTERVENTION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN YOUR BRAIN
COMMITTED TO BEING STRONG
PARTNERS IN THE EFFORT BECAUSE
THE MARKETING EXPERTISE.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WILL
BASICALLY HAVE A HEALTH PROGRAM
FINALLY WE ARE VERY EXCITED TO
ON THE DETAILS OF THE NEW WITH
THE BOBO AND LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH AN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE. EXCITING
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MODERN CHEMICAL
LEFT IN THE- AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE EIGHT MORE P. WAIT TO CALM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
BLINDED. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIE
CALLING FROM ACROSS THE
PACIFICA IN VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES WE WORK WITH-
HIGH RISK CHILDREN YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES- IN THEIR HOMES
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
IN THE SCHOOL I WOULD LIKE TO
REALLY JUST VERY BRIEFLY ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
MACHON FRANCIS FROM CHILDREN
NOW- I APPRECIATE AND APPLAUD
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
COMPOSED OF THAT THEY'LL BE.
RELEASING TOMORROW- BUT I
WANTED TO REALLY ALIGN MYSELF
AND OUR AGENCY AS WELL AS- MY
SISTER AGENCIES ACROSS.
WILDFIRES RIGHT NOW AS WE GET
THE RETURNING TO SCHOOL FROM
DISTANCE LEARNING OR ABOUT TO
ENTER THE SUMMER TIME PERIOD
AND I JUST REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
CALL OUT FILE MANY OF THE
LARGER SYSTEM CHANGES THAT ARE
MUCH NEEDED WILL TAKE TIME WE
DO HAVE FIRST RESPONDERS WITH
THEIR BOOTS ON TE GROUND.
COACH JOHN BRADY TO RUN OUT. TO
WORK WITH OUR CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES CHILDREN. SUPPORT
THE TEACHERS TO SUPPORT THE
FAMILIES. WERE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN WE ARE IN THE HOMES YOU
KNOW BEFORE SCHOOL ARE ALL
ELEVEN PM AT NIGHT- PLEASE
DON'T FORGET ABOUT YOUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS. THAT ARE OUT THERE
TO SERVE ALL OF THE NEEDS OF
THESE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
FOM THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
TO THEIR- HOUSE BEING AND YOU
KNOW MOST IMMEDIATELY EXILE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLINDED. TWO HUNDRED
NINETEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH
PLANTING ANYTHING YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
DAVE MY NAME IS JOHN IT SHOULD
BE REPRESENTING THE EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION CONSORTIUM A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION OF
LICENSED HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS EASY
EASY REPRESENTS THE NEXT CITY
PRIVATE PAY AND ON RIGHT HERE
IN OUR RECORDS BUT THE COURT
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN FROM
DIVERSE CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND. ECT MEMBERS HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY SIX CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA BUT THE PRE
QUEBEC HAVE TO BE THE THIRD.
OVER FORTY THOUSAND CHILDREN.
THE CANADIAN OFFICE THE GREAT
OF LAYING OUT ALL DIFFERENT
COMPANY REALLY PENDING BEEN
RECEIVED FROM THE FEDERAL. THE
MARCH TO DATE OUT OF THAT AND
EIGHTY MILLION OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE NONE OF THAT SO
IT'S BEEN PROVIDED SINCE NON
SUBSIDY PROVIDERS. ALL CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE STRUGGLING
TO COPE THANK YOU IMPACT
REGARDLESS OF THE POPULATION
THAT THEY ARE WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE FEDERAL
CHILD CARE STABILISATION FIND
THEM TO BE USED TO PROVIDE
GRANTS ALL CHILD CARE PROVIDER.
TO HELP STABILIZE THE FIELD NOT
JUST FOR SUBSIDY PROVIDERS WE
ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF THE EASY
COALITION ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE COALITION'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO ALL
PROVIDERS. OF SUBSIDIZED IN
NONSENSE RIGHT. THE FIELD
RECOGNIZES THAT ALL WRITERS
NEEDED TO SPEND I'M NOT THE
NEEDS OF PROVIDERS ARE
DIFFERENT WHICH IS WHY I WILL
GRANT THE NECESSARY TO ALLOW
FOR PROVIDERS PETER FRAENKEL
NEEDS WHATEVER THEY MAY BE IF-
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE
PRIORITY. THE STATEWIDE RATE
CHANGE. PROVIDERS AND BELIEVE
THAT THE BEST WAY TO DO THIS IS
WHAT GRANTS YOU OPERATORS BASED
ON THEIR LENGTH AND GRAVITY. WE
RESPECTFULLY COOK REQUEST THE
SENATE PRIORITY TO SUPPORT
WRITERS AND REMAINED OPEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC BEING
BANDAGE INCLUDE ALL PROVIDERS
DOCTORS SUBSIDY PROVIDERS. AND
THE HOLD HARMLESS ALL THESE ARE
IMPORTANT BUT NOT SUPPORT
WRITERS THAT HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO OPERATE WITH SEVERELY
REDUCED ENROLLMENT INCREASED
COSTS OVER HERE. I'M ABOUT BOTH
SUBSIDY AND NON. OF THE B. M.
LAUTENBERG. SUBSIDY AND
NONSENSE PAPER THANK WORKER ARE.
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO GO TO.
WITHOUT HI CHILD HE WILL BE
UNABLE TO REOPEN AND HE THE
PREVIOUS RECORD WHILE THEY GET
AWAY IMPORT OF SUPPORTING
HEALTH. THE LETTER THE DURING
THE CRITICAL TIME CANNOT BE-
OVERSTATED. AND THAT MAKES THE
PROVIDERS HE NEEDS HELP OR YEAH
LADY THE STATE WILL NOT RECOVER
AND LASTLY- MORE NOT THE
GOVERNMENT JANUARY BUDGET THE
GOVERNOR YEAH ME YESTERDAY
ABOUT SHOULD EARN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ENGINEERED BY
JURIES. CONCERNS THAT THE
TEACHING IN ENGINE PROPOSAL OF
THE NO CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
OPERATE ON VERY THIN MARGINS
AND ONLY WE CAN MAKE THE
FINANCES WORK IF I HAVE A FOUR
YEAR OLD TALK THAT THE VERY
HIGH COST CARE FOR IN INFANTS
AND TODDLERS. THE IMPACT OF
REMOVING ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS YOU
GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILL BE
HIGHER. COSTS IF YOU'RE
COMPARING AND- CLOSE CHILD CARE.
SO WE THOUGHT WE WERE FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO
CLEAR ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
CHAIR. HOW CARE AND- FOR ALL
WHILE KEEPING IN MIND THE NEXT
THE WORK FOR AND- SO THAT ALL
FAMILIES COMBINED EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION THAT AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CAN I ASK THE COLORS IT'S GOING
FORWARD NOW IT'S ON WE WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD FEEDBACK AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE LIKE LIKE YOU'RE
COORDINATED AND SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK IS SIMILAR SO IF YOUR-
COMMENTS ARE LIKE A LINE WITH
CHILDREN I MEAN IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND- AND IF YOU'RE
ALIGNED WITH SOMEBODY WHO IS
ALREADY SPOKEN AND BE GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLINDED TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY. EACH CARE THAN MEMBERS
CORY JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF BILL
THAT CALIFORNIA A COALITION
REPRESENTING OVER FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT AND
INVESTMENT IN CHILD CARE
FACILITIES SPECIFICALLY WERE
ADVOCATING FOR AT LEAST THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME FINE FOR THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THE
TEN AND ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT THE
PORT FOR ADDITIONAL BASES AND
FACILITIES ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PIECE MAKING THAT INVESTMENT
PICKS UP. FAITH HEALTHY AND
QUALITY LEARNING AND CARE
EXPERIENCES ARE ONLY POSSIBLE
IF PROVIDED AND STATE HEALTHY
AND QUALITY ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA MUST PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY LEARNING
FACILITY AT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CHILDREN AND THE
ADULTS TO EDUCATE THEM DEPEND
ON IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THE O. LINE OR ONE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
NINETY NINE HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND- WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE- RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY
HAVE- ONE OF YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES ON NURTURE HAS
PROVIDED AND REQUEST ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WHICH IS MUCH NEEDED TO
KERR LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR.
CHILD CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLINDED TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON A DOCTOR AND
CHECK WITH THE LARGER MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS
WENDY **** PREVENTING HAPPILY
SYCAMORES LOCATED IN LA COUNTY
SHARE THE SENTIMENTS MADE BY
CHILDREN NOW THE CALIFORNIA
LINE TELL THE FAMILY SERVICES
AND OTHER- MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES TO ELEVATE THE
PRESSING NEEDS OF STUDENTS AS
MANY OF THE MECHANIC CAMPUS
THAN LAST WEEK. WHEN I THANK
YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN DOCTOR PANIC
RECOGNIZING THE LONGSTANDING
LEAD COULD BUILD OUT THE.
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
WORKFORCE. SO THAT THERE CAN BE-
ENHANCE. CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY A CARE TO
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NICE COLOR HE'S. WHY
IN TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS ARE
INSTALLING TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP-
WE SUPPORT A STRONG CHARACTERS
DETERMINE THE INVESTMENTS
CONSIDERED THANK YOU FOR THAT-
WE ALSO PUT. FORTH A PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS THAT PORTHOLE CHILD
APPROACHES TO THEIR HEALTH WELL
BEING AND EDUCATIONAL. I'M
STILL AS NOTED THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION LIKE
URGENT NEEDS AS REFERENCE WHEN
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
INVESTMENTS IN MENTAL HEALTH
BEGAN IN EARLY CHILDHOOD AND
THE LOCAL SCHOOLS IN ADDITION
TO COUNTIES HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND TECHNICAL CAPACITY NOT
BURIED AT. OUR PARTNER WITH
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS LONG
TERM TO FULLY IMPLEMENT SCHOOL
BASED. SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE
COLOR PLEASE. BLINDED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALLISON BRETT THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THE HEARING AND
ALLOWING US TO SPEAK TO A LOT
OF GREAT OUT THE IDEAS OUT
THERE- SUPPORT ALL THE HELP FOR
THE CHILD CARE ECOSYSTEM I AM
WITHOUT TAKING A CHILDREN'S
CENTER I AM ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WE SERVE- FAMILIES-
THAT ARE BOTH PRIVATE. AND
FAMILIES THAT ARE SUBSIDIZED
THROUGH VARIOUS PARTNERSHIPS I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
ECHOING THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
FUNDING FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS.
TRULY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
FUNDING GO TO THE NEXT DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND NOT SPECIFICALLY TO
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AS FOR THE
CONCERNS THAT OTHERS HAVE
ALREADY NOTICED- MENTIONED.
SPECIFICALLY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TEXT COLOR PLEASE.
BLIND AT ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS WES
ANDERSON I OPERATE A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT PRESCHOOL AND INFANT
CARE CENTER IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN ITS
THIRTIETH YEAR OF OPERATION AND
SERVES FIFTY FIVE FAMILIES AT
THIS TIME. MY COMMENTS LINE
VERY WELL WITH- THE PREVIOUS
PANELISTS- NEED TO BOOST THE OF
EVERY TELL CALIFORNIA AND DONNA
STEERING OF CCRC WHO
ARTICULATED MANY IMPORTANT
POINTS WELL ENOUGH FOR ME-
PARTICULAR EXCUSE ME
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
MAKE DELIVERY OF CARE FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS PLATFORM TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND. SIXTY NINE.
HELLO YES MY NAME IS CARMEN
THOSE BONHOMIE AND CHUCK IT
PROVIDED AND IF YOU CHECK THE
RECORD OF THE GERMAN ACADEMY A
NUMBER OF RUNNING A PRESCHOOL
DAYCARE PROGRAM IN MY HOME FOR
THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS-
REALLY THANKFUL FOR THE
EXPERIENCE OF HOW THE COMPANY
COULD BE A GOOD SPEAKER AND I'M
ALSO SHARE SOME OF MY CONCERNS-
I MAY NOT BE ALLOWED ABOUT THE
ONLY THIS TIME HE'S CALLED ON
DAYCARE AND ALL THE FUNNY THAT
HE'S COMING I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FAMILY THE CAST HAD
INCLUDED- A TWENTY K. IS
STARTED AND I'LL BE RUNNING A
SUCCESSFUL PRESCHOOL. WHERE WE
WERE PROMOTING HEALTH AND
WELLNESS- BEING A LINCOLN
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WORKING
TIRELESSLY BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
PASSION ABOUT HOW WORKING WITH
WITH WITH- IT'S AN ALL AGES-
PLANNED TRANSITION- PLEASE CALL
CAME- OF COURSE WE IT'S HARD TO
COMPETE WITH FREE PROGRAMS AND
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE- I HAVE A
LOT OF PARENTS WHO WANT TO BE
IN THE PROGRAM- DATE THAT I
KNOW THAT THAT'S HARD FOR
BUYING. ANYTHING I'M BEING
PROVIDING THEM MAKING MY RATES
FLEXIBLE OPEN ALL THEIR MY
CONSTRAINTS AND OPENING A
CHECKING ACCOUNT AS OF TODAY
THREE DAYS BECAUSE AT LEAST
THAT AIDS IT'S HELPFUL FOR
FAMILIES TO AFFORD I'M LOOKING
FOR INCLUDE GET QUALITY
LOCATION BECAUSE THAT'S THE
QUESTION H. OW WE DO OUR WORK-
I'M PART OF THE CHILD THREE
SIXTEEN- BUT OVERTAKE YOU
ESCALATING- I'M A FIRE STARTER-
PROGRAM- GIVES WAY TO ESCALATE-
THOSE PROGRAMS WHEN THEY
STARTED THEY RAISE THE IMAGE OF
FAMILY THAT CARES OF PROGRAMS
THAT MANY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS.
ONE THIRTY IN A RESEARCH LAB
THE QUALITY OF OUR PROGRAMS- WE
GOT OUR PENSION- TRAINING AND
WE ARE ANY INDICATORS. ON
PROVIDING QUALITY PROGRAMS SO-
I REMEMBER WHEN I TRYING TO
THEM- SIX. WITH THE IN- CST
BEEP. THEY SAY. THE FIRST THAT
THEY FOR FAMILIES CARES AND BY
WINDOWS ENOUGH OUR- I WANT TO.
AND EVEN THOUGH MY APPROACH.
GOD THEY SAID HIGHEST SCORE IN
APPLICATION. LATER THAT WE WERE
DISAGREEING- BECAUSE WE WERE
FAMILY CARE AND THAT REALLY-
NOT JUST IN OUR SENSE OF THE
YOU KNOW WILL SO HIGH HOW TO
STOP ON THE ALL THESE QUALITY
PROGRAM AND THEN WE ARE NOT
INCLUDED SO. I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THIS TIME WHEN THE
FUNDING COMES- THAT PROGRAMS
ARE VOLUNTARY IN THE END GOING
TO THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
QUALITY LOCATION. PROMOTING
WELLNESS PROMOTING- YOU KNOW-
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL INTERVENTION
BECAUSE EARLY STAGE AND BEING
PART OF THESE QUALITY PROGRAMS
THAT I'VE RACINE- THIS TIME
DOES SUCH A FEW WITH A LADY AND
CHECK THE SAFETY AND THE
EFFORTS THAT WE NOW THEN- WE
GET IT TO BE INCLUDED IN THAT.
PROGRAM NOT JUST BASED ON- SO
WE ARE NOT HERE I MEAN WE DON'T
HAVE MANY THAT MANY CITY
CHILDREN BY THE WE HAVE THOSE
OPEN DOORS FOR A TENANT TO
CHOOSE WHATEVER THEY WANT TO
ALL. THAT WE ARE PART OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR SERVICE UP NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WIND IT HUNDRED
SEVENTY. THANK YOU ANDREA BY
HOW OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
SPEAKING ON THE ISSUE OF
STUDENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY US
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS
ARE CREDENTIALED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WORKING IN
SCHOOLS THEY ARE AUTHORIZED TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO STUDENTS. AND THEIR SERVICES
ARE REIMBURSABLE TO MEDIC COW
WE WELCOME THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND FUNDING ANY
COLLABORATION TO PROVIDE MORE
SERVICES TO STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS. UNDER EDUCATION CODE
FOLKS WORKING IN SCHOOLS
PROVIDING THE SERVICES ARE A
MUST BE SUPERVISED BY A
CREDENTIALED PERSON SO WE THINK
THAT SCHOOL THANKS HAVE A- ROLE
TO PLAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE. AND THE
RULES AND THE RULES AROUND
WORKING IN SCHOOLS PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WE
APPRECIATE THE OUTREACH TO DATE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND LOOK FORWARD T
WORKING WITH THEM AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO CRAFT THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT- MR
MODERATOR WE THANK YOU AND-
YOUR CALLS ARE AN- COMMENTS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US IF YOU DID
NOT GET A CHANCE- TO SPEAK
TODAY PLEASE- THE COMMITTEE
WOULD WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE OF A BUDGET
SOMEONE AND BUDGETS UP THREE.